Bye bye
boo!
Bye bye bye!
Go say it in the morning!
Hello everybody!
Hi hi hi Hello!
I just remembered something.
Wait!
Welcome in!
Welcome in, welcome in!
Howdy dody!
She almost bore Gore the drip!
I know!
What would I...
Wait.
Oop.
Oh yeah!
Does this hat mean anything to you?
you?
Does anybody know about this hat?
Does anybody know about this bike?
Does anyone know about this ghost?
Ni hao-di.
Welcome, welcome, welcome back to Contradiction.
Wait a second.
It says progress is 37%.
Cheats!
Cheats?
Wait, am I not almost done with this game?
Wait, We're not almost, like a couple, wait.
Wait.
Infinite bikes.
I wonder what...
I wonder what cheats there are.
37 seems low.
I feel like...
Well, maybe we won't finish today.
Oh, no.
This is only day one of 45.
Oh, yeah, 37% is the progress on chapter.
after one, of course.
No, I'm just kidding.
Well, if we don't finish today, that's okay.
I had another stream earlier.
I'm a little bit, after that, I'm a little bit.
Wait, why did I make that noise?
I was trying, sorry, I was trying to snore.
I'm feeling a little, If I did this eats an entire turkey
dinner in 30 minutes, would that mean anything to you?
It would mean you're hungry.
What did I have for dinner?
A potato.
Yeah, it has been a long day for me.
Yeah, it has been.
I, uh...
I woke up and, well, the night before, I was up late
finishing some things that needed to get done that day.
Then I woke up and was hit with a couple things that needed
to get done in the morning.
So I was like, I was rushing around this morning.
I'll just go until I feel like it.
It could be that I have a second the game you know some days
i'm a little you know some days i'm feeling strong enough to
go for many many times and some days my spiritual energy is
lower so it is what it is everybody has those times but
contradiction where did we end off on trying to think
finding the silver key no definitely not okay watching the
DVD we did the DVD that was xxx oh yeah and progress will be
what it will be exactly and if I don't beat it today we'll
beat it in a couple days so yeah we met the guy's dad uh did
you know about Simon's homebrew yet nobody will let me try
it I'm in Just discovered you in Doki over Christmas and
love your stream.
So I wanted to say hello.
Also, is there any sort of ritual to summon you?
TG, thank you!
The ritual.
No, I guess you could...
Oh, anything with a circle of metal gear, probably.
Like a summoning circle.
Fun fact.
Janks.
I was about to say, isn't his name jerks?
Chanks wasn't supposed to have a hat His actor Rupert Booth
showed up to film with a hat on And the developer decided to
throw it in It fits him so well Minto, do you know anything
about Magic Mint?
I should learn some magic tricks or two So I can be a Magic
Mint too I even thought I'd been lurking for a few years Now
I'm figuring my 30th birthday Would be a good time to break
that streak Thanks for keeping our spirits high all these
years.
You're the best boss.
Squint, happy birthday!
Oh my gosh!
You're coming out in the big three.
Oh my gosh.
Happy birthday!
Let us know and we will complete the ritual.
Not the goats.
I once had a dream that there were three goats telling me to
complete a ritual.
And I kept doing other things.
And the goats would be like, Wait, hold on.
The goats would be like...
No!
Me too!
You must finish the ritual!
No,
I had a dream like that.
And now, anytime...
Oh my goodness, sorry.
Anytime a ritual is brought up, it's like the goats are also
brought up.
It was so funny.
Well, shall we resume and see?
I'm going to resume the game.
We're at 8 p.m.
I think we have until...
Wait a second.
I think what I remember of this is we have until midnight,
no?
Deep mint?
midnight.
So that's another four hours now, isn't it?
And we've seen how long these hours have lasted.
Oh.
Hello, Minto and Ibu's IQ!
To be honest, I don't remember if I sent my daily Minto and
Ibu's IQ super chat, so I'm sending this just in case.
I thought you did though, Calmo.
Let's contradict this.
Contradict, shall we?
Yeah!
Yeah, the case closes at the end of the day for some reason.
I don't know why I thought at 10 p.m.
I don't know maybe we won't finish today but that's okay i'm
really sorry i kept it i think on the schedule and
everything i was like the thrilling conclusion but that's
all right let's see um paul and ryan both needed to need to
be asked about the dvd there are also things you haven't
asked james ryan and paul about yeah oh gosh there's
people's names i have to go back to paul and ryan's house
house.
A few more questions, if you don't mind.
Oh, we're at Paul.
Okay, I was like, wait a second, where am I?
Where am I?
Okay, so we... Sorry, I'm getting my bearings of what things
we've asked.
Okay, so let's start with the doll burning ceremony.
So this is the father, right, of Ryan.
Just, okay, let me, for anybody who's, uh, needs a little
reminder, which is also mean a girl died in a lake or a
girl's body was found in a lake and uh so we are detective
jenks and we're in this small town and um sorry someone said
skeddy doll oh dorko he said of look like these noodles that
I found that are spaghetti noodles but it just says hidden
vegetables and I think it's because they're partially made
with vegetables like they have instead of just like you know
regular spaghetti it's awesome and also is made with
vegetables and so the noodles are called hidden vegetables
spaghetti.
Everybody eat your hidden vegetables.
Sorry.
The noodles looked exactly like the spaghetti.
Wait.
No, sorry.
The doll looked exactly like
sorry.
The doll looked exactly like the noodles.
Hidden vegetables.
Musketi doll ate the veggies so they're in its belly.
Nah, she's got a snatched waist.
Look at that.
Okay, sorry.
You don't need magic mint when you've got sleep deprivation
mint.
Don't you think it's funny that it's called hidden
vegetables?
I feel like I'm six years old when I eat them.
Hidden Vegetables.
You must hide the veggies.
It's like when they hide the veggies within like a meal,
within like a bunch of cheese to trick the children into
eating it.
Or a dog.
Oh, crouching tiger hidden vegetables.
Anyway, okay, sorry.
Crouching fruit hidden vegetables.
I don't find it that funny, unfortunately.
Sorry.
You might be new here.
I laugh at things.
Anyway.
Sorry.
Murder.
The girl was killed.
uh uh the girl died the girl died uh that's not so funny but
this game is pretty funny um and we're in this town and it
turns out that she uh was a member of this society sorry not
society this business seminar that teaches you business and
um they're definitely not a cult uh they're definitely not a
cult yeah they're teaching you business everybody and how to
how to throw away your morals your giggles make my day i'm
glad you think so thank you or i'm glad that they do
yeah they teach business passionately they they they teach
the finest business and she was a member and then it turns
out that there was another guy that was part of this seminar
club this business club that also died a year prior to this
girl and so now we're interrogating the father and founder
the father of what are the the guys who runs the the cult
not cult and his father Paul okay let's ask him about the
doll what can you tell me about doll burning at Atlas not
very much it's one of Ryan's ideas my son is under the
illusion that he's a genius we're talking to Severus Snape
my my son is convinced that he's a genius oh why is seen
this before the writing looks familiar but no he's like I
made that with my wife last week auto hypnosis can you tell
me more about the auto hypnosis techniques used on the
course we don't use hypnosis on the course not at all not
anymore not anymore so how was it used is probably the wrong
word, Inspector.
It's nothing to do with the trances or things like that.
It was meant to force...
Force?
To help students.
Did you force them?
You can't force anybody into being hypnotized.
You have to want to be hypnotized.
It's not something out of your control.
You can't be hurt or damaged in any way by hypnosis.
So you've never put pressure on students to enter into
hypnosis?
It would be impossible to do so.
I'm being pressured into being hypnotized.
It's kind of true.
Yeah, I've heard that before too.
Like you have to be like susceptible to it.
You can't just be like, I don't want to be hypnotized and
then be hypnotized.
That is what they say.
What do you think differently?
Manga lied to me.
My thin books lied to me.
My dojin-shi say otherwise.
Okay, I think that's everything then to ask him about for
now.
Thank you.
Probably be back later.
I'm going to be using...
Until we get back into the swing of things, I'm going to be
using my tips.
So...
Wait, Paul and Ryan both need to be asked about that DVD.
So let's go to Atlas and let's go find Ryan.
Not with the...
My hat!
That's all they took!
It must have been deliberate.
Someone clearly wanted that back.
Nice and helpful of them to leave a piece of evidence
behind, though.
It's not the reusable tote bag.
The reusable grocery bag!
So what do we have now?
What is this?
Bag used in mugging.
Monarch costumes!
Bag from a shop called Monarch costumes was used during the
mugging.
Oh, whoops.
My bad.
To Atlas.
He's bald.
If he took off his hat, what if he what if I just put on my
hat and he lost it for this whole stream?
That would be crazy.
What was in the court?
Oh, this is the kitchen.
That's right.
This is where we found the DVD.
Leave the kitchen.
Why did...
So the DVD was of some guy like...
Or some person...
Uh...
Rummaging through people's things.
And being a little freak and stealing their stuff.
Oh, Ryan!
Let me in!
Excuse me!
Where are you?
Where could he be?
Okay, hold on.
What else?
Things that you haven't asked, Simon, Emma, James, Rebecca,
Ryan, and Paul.
Oh, that FOB?
That FOB looks like it...
Oh, the FOB!
The FOB!
Did you steal his hat?
No.
It looks too good on him.
I couldn't.
Then it would mean you stole his hat.
No, I did.
I didn't!
FOB!
Um...
Maybe?
Okay, there was...
I think I know where it goes to.
Let's go back here.
Behind the house.
Let's use it here.
The fob.
Oh!
I hope they don't hear that.
Looks pretty normal.
So, those are Ryan's guitars.
Kept in a garage.
Not really the best place to keep them.
Dan, do not move these.
Dan, don't move my guitars.
Ryan's guitars.
Is that...
Okay.
Collection of guitars belonging to Ryan was seen in the
garage at Brandon House.
Alright.
Interesting.
Kept in the garage.
the garage okay now we have to go to every single person
once again and ask them about every single thing that we
have discovered since we last talked to every single person
that we last talked to okay a few more questions if you
don't mind alright so where did we leave off never heard
that phrase before death okay james gave us a flyer so
everything from there all right the doll burning ceremony
let's do it i've saved 12 on gamer subs using your code
thank you for using my code thank you thank you so much i
really appreciate it thank you i find i i find that i like
forget about withdrawing the the gamer subs money and then
it'll be like I get a reminder to get it and I'll be like,
wait, this really helped me with like a project that I had
spent money on.
So yeah.
Oh, I just remembered something.
I gotta...
Wait.
Ah, I just remembered something else I gotta do.
Okay, anyway, I'll... I'll...
What do you know about doll burning?
Doll burning?
What sort of doll burning?
It doesn't mean anything to you.
No.
Should it?
No, that's okay.
I think he doesn't know anything atlas auto hypnosis ever
heard of auto hypnosis James self-hypnosis yeah and what do
you know about he does know something it's another name for
scrying some people call it auto hypnosis I call it scrying
right so you're saying scrying is just self-hypnosis scrying
you can scry on anything I don't use right now I can scribe
watching the clouds maybe the water on a lake in the
moonlight and when you're watching the water what happens
you go into a trance you lose yourself in your unconscious
you go deeper and deeper you swim around try not to go too
deep because if you go too deep start drowning you get
dragged down to the bottom as long as you stay coming to the
surface again.
Then you wake up and see the world as it really is.
It's like a journey to a place people talk about, but no
one's ever seen.
You're thinking about Case, aren't you?
What makes you say that?
She bought a mirror.
Sold her one last year.
Was she into using mirrors like that?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No idea, but she bought one.
Right.
vine last year we i think we heard that because uh we heard
that before because her friend said that what he i'm going
too deep into my my what is that my mind palace
i'm scrying in my mind palace right now everybody please do
not disturb
the scry cave Do you know anything about monarch costume?
Seen this anywhere before?
Nope.
No, that was nothing.
All right.
That's all for the moment.
Thank you.
Okay, thank you.
Bye-bye.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
James is the biggest Chuni in England, and he's our only
ally.
Okay, now time to go talk to Simon.
Simon keeps getting weirder and weirder.
And Emma.
couple more questions if that's okay all right oh we are
gonna ask about Ryan's guitars okay um for let's see doll
burning auto hypnosis he did tell us about the auto hypnosis
do you know this bag you've seen this you know the shop yeah
yeah I know the shop I had something from them last year I
think this is for a party I assume yeah yeah something like
that something like the hired a costume from the shop last
year
is it a robe type costume that you might have bought from
said costume store and maybe with a freaky mask yeah was it
from the section called cult cult items perhaps
Hmm.
What do you know about Ryan's guitar collection?
Not a whole lot.
I know he brought a guitar to one of the groups once, at the
end of one of the stages.
That's the only time I've seen him with a guitar.
Modern day Elvis.
Let's go see what Emo says.
Be back later on, if that's okay.
Mm-hmm.
uh go the shop have you used it no but i know where it is
would you tell me where it is what do you know about ryan's
guitar collection i know he plays because he tried to buy
one off me do you play what i used to i used to be in a band
but i was a singer as well so i got away with it singer as
well yeah i used to sing in the band every night but uh
Sometimes it was in a pub, but usually at Rebecca's.
What was that called?
It was called Blackstone.
And this guy from a record company once came to see us, and
he said the band was rubbish, but that I was good.
So after that, I don't think they liked me much, and then we
broke up after college.
Can't high talent.
Why'd he say it like that?
Wait, so what did she say about, didn't know Liam very well,
but you were in the band with him excuse me that's a
contradiction yeah I remember that what band you sang in
Blackstone who else was in the band just a few people from
college including Liam James guy sounds like awful lot like
a drood why did you say you didn't know him no it's not that
I just thought you meant that I didn't know about his
suicide did you?
no I was...
Away on holiday.
When he died?
Yeah, I only knew him through the band.
She definitely knows more than she's saying.
She was in the band with Liam, but didn't know about his
problem.
Bruh.
Not sure I believe you, Emma.
Not sure I believe you.
Emma has lied to us, I think, the most out of anybody in
this game so far.
Only knew Liam through the band Blackstone was on holiday
the night Liam died.
I don't remember if we know anything else about...
We didn't mention his problem either.
I feel like there might be something else, but I don't know
where to hit her with it.
For now, we leave.
Okay, that's it for now.
Okay, bye bye.
See you.
Crawls out her window.
Rebecca, okay, Rebecca, sorry.
Rebecca How am I supposed to find Ryan?
I don't know where that guy is
Anybody?
Well, actually, we'll just Let's just call Rebecca She might
be He might be in the restaurant Alright, when is the last
thing I talk to you about?
The bag, okay Have you seen this before, anywhere?
Well, I know the shop Costume shop just outside the village
it not personally but i think ryan might have yeah we know
and his guitar collection hit her with oh emma one more
thing yeah just hopped in did i miss much not really not
much at all um oh we did get mugged the dvd that we had that
said xxx yeah that got taken from us we got mugged i think
that's the biggest thing that's happened so far have you
seen this before anywhere well i know the shop sorry shop
just outside the village ever used it not personally but i
think sorry i didn't mean to do that one again the guitar
collection there we go does ryan play the guitar he tries he
does keep wasting money on them though i think he believes
if he buys the right one he'll suddenly turn into jimmy
hendrix sad really i just Let him play in his room.
As long as he plays in there, I don't mind.
Dang.
Let's Ryan play in his room.
Ryan is nine years old.
Thank you.
Probably be back later.
All right.
Let's go back to Paul and Ryan.
Paul and Ryan.
Eh.
Ask you a couple more things.
Yeah, he does need to, he needs to practice.
Have you seen this before?
No, I don't think so.
You don't recognize the shop?
No.
Is there someone else who works at Atlas, someone who may
have been there tonight?
No.
Is there a cleaner?
A cleaner?
Comes at strange times, but then he's a strange boy.
Work experience.
Why do I like the mean lady so much, am I okay?
and it counts, but it didn't work out.
You are just a masochist, maybe.
I'm glad that this game could help you recognize that.
Didn't he already say that shop that he uses that shop for
props?
Oh, let me see.
Let me see.
Maybe the the
mask thinks it's from monarch but he doesn't know where the
bag is you're so right aha do you visit monarch costumes a
lot no I used to go in there occasionally why but you do
know the shop yes of course I do you see Paul I thought you
said you didn't know where this bag was from well maybe I do
why would you say you don't used to put over my head paul
buy a mugger would you like to tell me something are you
suggesting that i had something to do with your mugging did
you did you you really ask the most ridiculous questions of
course i didn't so why did you lie about yeah it's literally
written on in fact i didn't have anything to do with your
mugging inspector but i might know somebody who did go on go
on mention jason to you as a cleaner oh yeah you know you
did actually At some point, told Jason that the DVD mustn't
be removed from the site.
So, when he saw you take it, he simply thought that he was
doing us a favour by, well, getting it back.
That's weird.
He isn't exactly what you'd call one of Darwin's best
examples.
Oh, my God!
So what's on the DVD that's so special?
All right, it was something I did myself a little stunt I
pulled to amuse the students.
I pretended to steal from the students.
I emphasized the word pretended.
The students knew all about it afterwards.
Everything was above board.
Oh, right.
Steal from students.
Why?
We were doing a piece about pushing the limit, so I decided
I, I would show them how it was done.
Oh, don't look so serious, Inspector.
I returned everybody's things immediately afterwards, no
harm done.
And when was this?
Last year sometime.
It was just a prank, bro.
A third eye?
Atlas.
Third eye, I think.
And this was before or after Liam died.
Well, since you'll probably find out anyway, it happened to
be on the night that Liam died as it happens.
Before you ask, no, I didn't steal from him.
You seem so proud of yourself.
Do you think it's a good idea to encourage students to
steal, Paul?
I wasn't encouraging students to steal.
Policemen are so literal.
It is shades of grey, Inspector.
Much as the Force might like it, it doesn't divide neatly
into blacks and whites.
Now, if you don't mind, you'd have to excuse me for a
moment.
You know where the door is.
Oh!
You know where the door is?
Wow.
I'm pretending to steal.
You see, he was quick enough to claim he didn't steal from
Liam.
What kind of stunt was that anyway?
And Liam dying later the same night is just all a bit too
suspicious.
I agree, I agree.
Liam was heartbroken he wasn't stolen from.
Okay, now we...
Oh wait, oops.
We have to go back to Atlas?
I'm trying to find this dang guy.
Maybe he's in the restaurant.
Maybe Ryan is getting a thick, juicy burger.
Actually, what do they sell?
at a british restaurant british restaurant pub combo let's
see uh
garlic ginger no no no garlic cracker sizzler
and crackers so many crackers subliminal no sorry this one's
this one's sold out anyway breakfast bangers and mash I know
that I know that
turkey tin foil legs pickled red cabbage wait I think whoa
Uh...
Peas?
Steak.
Okay, anyway.
Uh, we're heading to...
Atlas again.
One more time, baby.
Gotta find this guy.
Ryan, open up!
This is the police!
He's not here.
Hint.
Simon, Emma, Rebecca, Ryan, and Paul yet.
What?
There is more stuff?
So many people, wait, what did I not ask about?
Oh, the theft stunt!
That's right.
I forgot we got the new...
Just a few more questions, if you don't mind.
This guy comes back...
Drawing.
This guy comes back every 20 minutes.
I can't stand him anymore.
What do you know about Paul stealing money from students?
Part of a stunt or something?
Did he do that?
I've never heard about anything like that.
No, it might be part of the risk-taking thing, though.
The risk-taking.
Explain that.
Well, it's part of the course.
You have to do something dangerous or risky, something you
wouldn't normally do.
Something dangerous?
Well, not dangerous, just risky.
Like, saying something you wouldn't normally say to someone,
or doing something unusual.
Like stealing from other students.
Like...
We didn't do anything like that.
Doing a dance in public.
of the course anyway and you're not allowed to do anything
that would hurt or offend anyone or you're not allowed to do
anything really bad it's all pretend really it's just a bit
old for a business course it works though finally finally
someone acknowledges it this is strange for a business
course this is weird for a business course thank you
probably be back later why are we
masks what do you know about Paul Rand Paul the slime you've
obviously met him then yes I am I was reincarnated what do
you know about him committing a fake theft during one of the
courses what about him going through people's bags yeah you
try that thing on me as well weirdo what so you were at
third eye yes yes I I went there for a few months after
college and I left because I hated it and I didn't know
Atlas was the same thing and i went with simon does simon
know that no i didn't want to burst his bubble so i didn't
say anything so he doesn't know you went to third eye no ah
so is that where you met ryan as well yep right what uh what
didn't you like about the course well it was just he hates
telling the truth it was stupid they just made you do things
to other people and be abusive just to prove that you could
and i absolutely hated it what sort of things oh just just
stupid things, nasty things to prove that you could do it.
It was about not feeling guilty.
Ah.
And it was horrible, that's why I left.
And is Simon doing all of this stuff now?
No.
No, I think they had to stop because it was just getting
ridiculous.
I think somebody got arrested or something.
Very interesting.
Who got arrested?
Join Third Eye after leaving college.
Was at Third Eye when Paul pulled the stunt.
Simon doesn't know Emma.
Wait, OK, hold on.
Liam only knew him through the band Blackstone but she went
to Third Eye
no because he was because Liam was also at Third Eye so she
would have known him I don't know what you're about this all
sounds perfectly in line with high end businessmen
hmm hmm But only knew him through banned Blackstone.
But also, she said she was on holiday.
He did that the same night he died.
Okay, hold on.
Okay, there's multiple things we got here on her.
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
Was on holiday?
Was that third eye when Paul pulled the stunt?
There we go.
We got him.
So, you witnessed Paul's money-stealing stunt.
Is that right?
Yes.
But you weren't there when Liam died.
Don't quite understand that, you see, because Paul pulled
the stunt on the same night.
Liam died later that evening.
Why is he always lying?
I must have mixed up.
So you don't know anything about Liam's death, even though
you were there on that night?
No.
Emma.
I think you better explain, don't you?
Well, it's the stupid course.
it oh my god we were all told to do stupid things and and
then that thieving thing happened and so take a breath I
can't I can't believe I was Liam killed himself because of
me why um Liam had a a birthmark on the side of his face did
you say it was no one would mention anything even though we
all knew it was there was that your risk they all thought it
was ugly oh you've done it so i thought i say something and
i even asked paul if it was okay to say what did he say he
said he wouldn't lie and liam killed himself liam's dad
because of me
Emma, I'm quite sure you regret what you said, but I really
don't think you caused Liam's death.
There's always more to these things than meets the eye.
It wasn't your fault.
We can't tell Simon, please.
There's no tears, by the way.
Thank you.
Not a single tear has rolled down her cheek, by the way.
9pm!
9 o'clock Poor Emma I suppose it's possible that what she
said led to Liam's death But I really doubt it I blame the
rands before I blame her
Did we get anything from her saying that?
Emma's guilt She said don't tell Simon But what if we My bag
Simon do you know about Emma's guilt?
Do you know about how guilty she feels?
Ask about a few more things, please.
Oh, Jenks has promised not to discuss this with Simon!
He's a man of his word!
Aww.
Straight to snitch.
No, I was testing his loyalty.
And he passed.
He passed the test.
how honorable jinx is a good guy a couple more questions if
that's okay all right the theft theft Paul's theft stunt did
you know about Paul's money stealing at Atlas are you
talking about a particular incident or just in general it's
something he did on the course stunt and what did he do
exactly oh well he pretended to steal from the students that
doesn't about.
Paul's stunts usually involve throwing fancy dress parties
with scantily clad girls or women dressed as nurses.
That's his usual fetish.
Who's the last party he threw?
Um, sometime in the summer.
I didn't stay long.
What's happening?
And atlas.
Nurse fetish, atabus, discourse.
What's going on?
It's unlikely Rebecca would know anything about this with
Lin.
Aw.
What is happening?
Last party Paul threw was sometime in the summer.
Paul often throws fancy dress parties.
Be back later on, if that's okay.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, yeah, I think this is the one I need to go to.
Yes, Abbey Farm.
There we go.
Just a business course.
I wonder if we're going to be able to go to the...
It's better go to the costume store James wouldn't know
James wouldn't know okay Can I come in and ask you a few
questions rummaging through my notes.
You know what never mind.
Bye-bye Okay Back to Paul and Ryan.
I haven't seen Ryan in so long Where's this guy at?
Maybe he's back here.
Orion, Orion, where are you?
Ryan.
Ryan must be lonely, I think so.
Ask you a couple more things, please.
I don't think he was the one that mugged us.
Actually, the guy who mugged us wasn't wearing a mask or
anything.
Oh, I forgot to ask about the guitar.
Oh, wait, I think he kicked us out before we could ask about
the guitars.
Does Ryan play the guitar?
Ryan?
Ryan couldn't get a tune out of a radio.
He's turned deaf.
Try the Alice location at 90 and now.
Oh, true!
Then maybe they're done with their ceremony.
It was never going to happen.
Ryan can't play the guitar.
Ryan couldn't have become professional.
Oh, my God.
Dang.
Do you think Emma's criticism of Liam on that last night led
to his suicide?
I doubt it helped.
Do you encourage Emma to criticize him?
I didn't encourage Emma to do anything.
I merely told her what we told every student to do to
express themselves as they wanted.
And so she wanted to express how ugly the birth mark was.
Wouldn't it?
However, I didn't expect her to criticize his...
birthmark if that's what it was that's a decision she took
herself so you didn't know her well no not at all hardly
knew Emma I think we know that that's a contradiction with
the necklace bought a freedom necklace for a student maybe
yes huh and yet you say you didn't know emma uh yet you
bought her a freedom necklace i don't remember saying
anything about buying emma a necklace so you didn't buy her
one so you did buy her one so that means you must have known
her and quite well too stop making such a big thing about
this inspector look i've been around a few years the clock
is ticking And I admit I have an embarrassing weakness.
For nurses.
For attractive women.
And nurses.
It was a stupid mistake.
Attractive women and nurses.
But that's all it was.
So you're saying you tried it on with her?
No, I didn't try it on.
I bought her a necklace.
I'm not aware that there's a law against buying presents,
unless, of course, the Third Reich has been elected.
if that's a crime locked me up being attracted to emma was
old enough to make decisions liking attractive women and as
a matter of fact she decided that she didn't want to be
bothered as an old fool like me so nothing happened no
mistakes nobody got hurt all right like father like son no
surprise did she sleep yeah did she sleep with the dad and
the side paul has tried it on with like father like son
Once tried to date, but...
Don't say, oh Yakodon.
Emma!
Alright, let's head to Atlas.
Atlas!
Man.
Emma is the talk of the town, it seems.
Oh, were these here before?
Were those boxes there before, or...
Maybe there's something new in here?
I feel like I'm playing an anomaly again.
Were these things here before?
Did that thing move?
Was that chair always that color?
Ah!
The door...
Okay, they are out.
Awesome.
Is the ceremony finished?
Oh, I'll clean.
No more doll burning in here.
Mito, show us your Mito's.
No, thank you.
Not cannibalism.
54 minute for generational double-tip.
A few more questions if you don't mind.
Okay, we have so much to ask Ryan right now.
Holy cow.
Okay, we're starting at the doll burning ceremony.
So tell me more about this doll burning.
It's a symbolic ceremony.
We perform every few weeks on the course.
What's it about?
It's about burning your old personality and finding a new
one, a better one.
So the dolls are...
The dolls are my personality.
They represent you from the past.
Each doll has a picture of a student as a child or a
teenager.
they burn the doll and symbolically destroy their old
personality.
It's quite simple but effective, I find.
And why did that girl shout?
Because it's an emotional thing.
She quite clearly become very attached to her doll.
They do spend the first month with them.
We tell them to take the doll everywhere with them before
they actually go through the doll burning.
And you believe that's a good thing?
Destroying your past?
It's like when they give you an egg.
Of course it's a good thing, Inspector.
Tell us to say that it's your baby.
We're all shackled to our past, particularly you by the
sound of it, perhaps.
Perhaps we should make it all of you, Inspector, and burn
that, what do you think?
No, thank you.
You're probably right.
I'm not sure it would do any good anyway.
But what if I prefer my Skeddy personality?
But Skeddy, Spaghetti is my whole personality.
Oh, Hamito.
So sassy.
He almost took a sip there.
Hi.
It's like when they give you an egg in school and they're
like, this is your baby, now you have to take care of it.
And if it dies, you fail.
And you become attached to your baby egg.
I don't hit nervous.
Can you tell me about auto hypnosis well what would you like
to know do you use it on the course we dip into it
occasionally but it's not a major feature of the course I
would say that well a minority of the students know how to
use it but the majority wouldn't know and have a clue it's
not a requirement of the course no not at all we don't we
don't ask people to do things that they're not comfortable
with there's no bribery no coercion we're thinking about
phasing auto hypnosis out actually Well, to be perfectly
honest with you, Inspector, it doesn't actually work very
well.
I think that's a lie.
Believes auto-hypnosis doesn't work.
Okay, hold on.
Let's check the scry...
What do you say?
Hmm.
Oh, my God.
There's so much.
If you don't believe in auto-hypnosis, then how do you
explain your good thoughts?
I didn't realize you were a musician.
Oh, well, I'm not really a musician.
I mean, I dabble a little bit.
To be quite honest with you, I'm far more interested in
collecting guitars.
You're not in a band.
Well, I did audition.
I did audition a few years ago.
What I say a few years ago, of course, I mean about 20 years
ago.
Doesn't time fly?
20 years.
What was that?
Oh, I can't remember.
Something's stone.
Aren't they all called something stone?
Hammerstone.
That's it.
And you still collect?
Hammerstone, huh?
I haven't bought a guitar for over a year.
I feel I've moved on.
20 years?
One's auditioned for a band called Hammerstone.
Okay, hold on.
Let's see if he knows anything about...
What is it, Blackstone?
Uh...
I'm seeing...
Ask him about this.
I
guess not hasn't said anything about it all right the bag do
you know what this is well I think it's a bag is it a bag
inspector the shop oh yes the costume shop yes we used to
hire from them for the course well yes for the course at the
end of each stage we have a little party and we ask students
to dress up or try acting out being somebody new their new
selves as it were could you explain a bit more new selves is
all just role-playing one of the main elements of the course
is learning how to act how to be you need to be in any given
situation I think you'll agree inspector that business is
about being the right person in the right situation at the
right time what he does it helps them to detach themselves
become somebody new pretend you know you know the kind of
thing is surprising what a little bit of cross-dressing can
do for you inspector you should try it not at this stage hmm
wait what did he just say
hello what are you hello sorry
it just took out I was just trying to I was trying to figure
out my headphones if it's my headphones or my ears Because
I've been wearing my headphones all day.
They're like kind of hurting my ears.
Like my in-ear monitors.
Hold on.
And I like had my left one in only.
But the game was really quiet.
And I'm like, am I deaf in this ear?
Or is it my earbud?
I can't tell.
No, I think it's my earbud.
I don't know why.
Hmm.
okay anyway let me try Helen oh yeah it's definitely my left
earbud is like lower than my right one hmm yeah it is it is
plugged in all the way let me try again
hmm Uh, oh.
Maybe they do need to be clean.
Could just be a clog.
Could be.
Too much ecto wax, maybe.
Okay, I'm gonna switch to my other headphones real quick
then.
Give me one second, sorry about that.
These aren't that old, so I was like, huh.
Okie dokie Um What do you know about Emma's guilt?
Your Your papa is I can't I can't get over You should try
cross-dressing Sometime What an out-of-pocket thing to say
Is he wrong?
You decide Is he wrong?
White hair and hearing loss My oh she's getting old.
Okay, anyway, we're moving on.
What do you know about your father's money-stealing stunt?
He's right.
Well, yes, that was something that Dan decided to do as part
of the shock aspect of the course.
But he went too far.
You believe.
Shock.
He usually does.
And do you think it did have anything to do with Liam's
death?
No, no, no, no.
Liam wasn't like that at all.
I mean, that was just a simple I mean, Liam had his own
problems, but he didn't have any problems with the money
shock stunt.
No.
Stunt's not related to Liam's suicide.
Hmm.
You were shocked!
What do you know about Emma Bowman criticizing Liam before
his suicide?
I was there.
I witnessed it.
Uh, well, I know Emma blamed herself for his death.
20 years no well she was upset and all of that but um i i
wouldn't blame her inspector i i really don't think she had
anything to do with it at all you don't think leon was a
very confident person very outgoing very strong individual
or so it seemed i think people are free to do what they like
even something as irreversible as bumping themselves off sad
though that is of course
Hmm.
Edible, thank you so much for the, for the, for the
Supertown.
Thank you.
Uh-huh.
He's not sus at all.
I know he's, it seems to be getting kind of flustered about
it.
Let's see what about, I'll let, um.
Seemed happy.
Liam was strong and outgoing.
Makes people are free to do what they like.
That's it for the time meeting.
Thank you.
Did I get everybody?
Hold on, I'm gonna...
Did I get...
What happens after an Atlas meeting?
I don't know.
What happens after they go home?
Um...
We went to the reading room.
Already.
Did they hang out in here?
No, we already went in here.
That's my bad.
Do they go to the pub?
Do they go get drinks?
Maybe they're...
Wait, maybe they're in the restaurant now.
Ding ding.
A few more questions, if you don't mind.
Uh, never mind.
Thank you.
Probably be back later.
after...
Maybe they all gather in the forest?
That's the only other thing that I could think of.
Let's go here.
Into the clearing?
Are they gathered here?
No.
There.
Oh, whoops.
My bad.
Back to the clearing, back to the junction, back to the
clearing, back to the junction.
To the jetty.
Woods entrance.
To the end...
of the path?
What the heck do they do after an Alice meeting?
They all just hang out?
Inside?
Oh, I just noticed.
That'll come in handy.
I don't know why I never remember to buy
one.
Wait, did you guys see the glitching or no?
Oh, you did it?
Oh, no!
That's why I was going like, whoa!
Was there a place that was dark that we couldn't go to?
Do you know anything about this flashlight?
Wait, oh no, try using this.
Oh, I remember!
I remember at the pub!
At the pub!
Here.
I remember.
Oh?
What does that say?
Car insurance?
Oh, you don't know.
You just stole that.
You do not know where that's been.
Janks.
E-will.
Devil worshippers.
Oh well.
And there's the mask symbol again.
Oh my god, it's Lightning McQueen.
Looks like someone's been trying to make a point.
Jenks is not pretending.
E-will!
Vandalized car photos.
E-will.
I'm going to see if there's a...
If we call the chief.
See if it happens.
Okay.
Hmm.
He will.
Devil worshippers.
I can't tell what's the difference between a busy tone or
its calling.
I think.
Never mind.
Time to go ask everybody about the photos.
It's better.
A couple more questions, if that's okay.
know anything about these nope nope
okay bye that's all for the moment thank you do you know
anything nope bugs bunny meme no
I know, he's so freaking helpful with anything.
A few more questions, please.
Thank you.
Do you know what these are?
Yes, that's Ryan's car.
Another toy he managed to ruin.
Ruin?
It was vandalized sometime last year.
You know who did it?
I don't believe anybody was ever prosecuted for it.
But do you know who did it?
What do you think you know?
Doesn't think anyone was prosecuted doesn't mean that you
don't have an inkling of an idea of who did it.
Be back later on.
That's a very curious language you're using, mister.
Snape vibes.
I know!
He has such Snape vibes.
Rebecca's pub.
Yeah, there's the symbol on the side.
Exactly.
Ding-a-ling!
Ask you a couple more things, please.
It's time to go to everybody at the office.
Have you ever seen these?
It's Ryan's car.
It got vandalized last year.
His camera had been stolen, so I took pictures.
Whoever did it made a mess, didn't they?
That game is glitching again.
But nobody was prosecuted for it.
Not that I remember.
The insurance paid out, though.
Hmm.
It's like stuttering, kind of, you know?
He's a solid snake.
Didn't think anyone was prosecuted.
Brian's camera had been stolen.
Rebecca took the photos.
Okay, that's it for now.
Thank you.
All right, to Simon and Emma.
We're going...
Wait a second!
Back to the main road.
Do they go to the village hall after the...
No, oops.
Oh, my bad.
They go to the village hall after.
No.
Never mind.
Yeah, if it seems fine on stream, that's totally good.
It's just funny for me.
Yeah, back again for a singular question.
Just a few more questions, if you don't mind.
A few more questions, if you don't mind.
Have you seen these before?
Hmm.
No.
Don't know the car.
And it's always the same thing.
thing do you know this probably be back later okay bye uh
emma do you know do you know anything about these
nope sorry doesn't recognize the photos why do i feel like
she's lying i can't trust literally anything she says
anymore you don't know you don't know about this even though
you were dating Ryan and also there's
like literally nothing you probably be back later hmm we'll
threaten her we'll be like I tell Simon everything if you
don't tell me what's going on tell me the whole truth and
nothing but the truth I
will We'll tell on you.
Ask about a few more things, please.
It isn't worth asking Ryan about the red torch that I stole
from his...
Do you know what...
Establishment.
These are.
Oh, yes.
That's my old car.
It was vandalized.
I took those for the insurance company.
Where did you find those?
At the pub.
Uh, you know who did this?
Yes.
A girl called Lisa Blint.
She was on the course, a very strange girl.
And why did she write the words, devil worshippers all over
your car?
Well, she was a very strange girl.
She had a lot of psychological problems.
I'm not entirely sure, Inspector.
A poor girl split too.
She took a dislike to the course for some particular reason.
I couldn't quite put my finger on it.
And she asked for a refund.
I declined.
And she decided to spray her disapproval all over my car.
A good thing to spray, isn't it?
worship us well she was a very odd girl inspector maybe she
thought it was a way of getting back at us I had no idea did
Rebecca know about it well yes she did but I was I wasn't
about to unleash Rebecca on her she can be quite fierce
sometimes you know and I mean the girl wasn't vindictive she
had psychological problems she lives in the village actually
oh the run-down house at the end of the lane can't miss it
we have a new person to ask literally oh no we have a person
to ask everything about oh god lisa lives alone at the end
of the lane that's all for the moment thank you she sprayed
her code all over his car spread my code this one this lane
could that be where lisa lives run down house at the end of
the lane that's what ryan said wasn't it i seen i see a bush
unless it's this one
New Challenger appears.
Oh my god, we have to ask her about the bike.
What if she knows something about the bike?
What if, what if, what if?
Hello?
Is it Lisa?
Yes.
Inspector Jenks, I'm investigating an incident in the
village.
I wonder if I could ask you a few questions.
What sort of incident?
I'd rather come in and discuss it if that's alright with
you.
I promise I won't take long.
I won't take long.
I'll just be back like 50 times.
I'll just go in here yes I have to go out in a minute oh oh
look I can come back later I might not be here what did you
want to ask I just wanted to ask you did you know cave vine
no right well I heard that you're familiar with Atlas the
life skills training company what do you want to know about
Atlas well you got Very interesting.
Because I reacted badly.
So would anyone.
Now why do you say that?
Because they're devil worshippers.
Devil worshippers.
They're making demons appear.
They're tricking everybody.
They're getting people to join up.
Then they're putting demons inside them.
You can see them.
see who demons where could you see them in the mirrors i was
gonna say in the mirrors any mirror you can't get rid of
them they stay inside you so how did you get rid of them i
didn't oh you still see them you got the demons in you
I just don't look.
I put all the lights on.
I make sure it's all bright.
I put them on when I need to look in the mirror.
If I make sure everything is bright, I just see myself
without...
Power outage.
Seeing the other person.
Other person?
Who is the other person?
She's like me, but older.
It's like her eyes sink in.
She's all wrinkled with a wrinkled mouth.
Wrinkled mouth?
Like she's dying.
And then I realize I'm her.
I'm not me anymore.
What's happening?
Drink some water.
The door just opened by itself.
I'm sorry, I have to go now.
I'm sorry.
Drink some water.
Just leaves this guy that she never knew just met just now
in her home.
Well, that was curious.
A very fragile and disturbed person.
and utterly convinced that Atlas are worshipping the devil.
How are Ryan and Paul going to get out of this one?
How are they going to get out of this one?
Great question.
Did she try Simon's homebrew?
No, she tried the...
The magic mint.
She tried the magic mint.
Persona 6?
Yeah, she tried the magic mint and maybe it messed up her
brain.
Long time VOD watcher.
Hope you have a great day.
Yo, Jembo, thank you.
You too, you too.
Let's go to the Brandon house.
Thanks for the super chat.
A couple more questions, if that's okay.
Lisa's accusation.
Do you know anything about devil worship, Paul?
I beg your pardon.
Devil worship?
Satanism?
The devil?
666.
six i heard atlas had elements of satanism on the course you
are misinformed we're a training company we're not devil
worshippers what kind of a question is that so you have no
interest in the occult no inspector i have no interest in
the occult any more than i have interest in pool vaulting
cheese making or snake charming anything else you want to
know that i'm not interested in that's fine thanks
I have an interest in snake charming.
Be back later on if that's okay.
It's not okay, but I know you'll be back.
He just can't stay away.
Anytime.
Anytime Jenks learns a new fact, he's got to tell everybody
in town.
He's got to be like, hey, did you know about this?
What do you think about this?
What do you think when you see this?
Do you know about this?
knock knock i have one new question to ask of you has devil
worship ever been part of the course ryan ever am i correct
in assuming that you have spoken to lisa blint you would be
she's been telling me all about the atlas obsession with
satanism ryan then if you've met lisa blint then you will
have worked out for yourself that she has a very vivid
imagination she also has Psychological problems.
Diagnosed psychological problems as a matter of fact.
What's wrong with cheese, Vixen?
Where did she get the idea that you lot were devil
worshippers?
I really have no idea.
The girl is insane.
Was it the Dalburner?
She's frightened of her own shadow, bless her.
She actually thinks that demons are possessing her even now.
Oh, we know.
You really can't trust a word she says.
So you are saying there has never been any devil worship at
Atlas.
even know what devil worship is inspector it's not something
i particularly know anything about i certainly don't recall
anyone ever having worshipped the devil at atlas we even
tried to help the poor girl by paying for some treatment but
she didn't want it really it's not easy to offer someone
help when they think that you're the problem that's a lie
yeah doesn't know anything about devil worship oh come on
you said yourself that you used to read about black magic
and satanic rituals i know you so you used to read a lot
about voodoo and satanic rituals but you don't know anything
about devil worship well obviously i just meant we don't
worship the devil we're not devil worshippers here at atlas
inspector ridiculous but the point is ryan that you claim
not to know anything about it but admitted you were obsessed
with it when you were younger.
Are you sure none of that made its way onto the Atlas
course?
And that Lisa isn't basing her beliefs on anything within
that course?
Lisa isn't basing her beliefs on anything other than her own
imagination, Inspector.
Look, we do use some techniques that some students find
difficult, disturbing.
Disturbing?
It's business!
We encourage them to see things differently, that's all.
And some people simply aren't up to that.
Some people, like Lisa, That's why we introduced the
aptitude test.
What's the aptitude test?
This.
Do you...
How do you feel when you see these numbers?
Six, six, six.
We ask students to fill in an aptitude test.
Medical history, psychological issues, that kind of thing.
He put the test down!
Any medication that they are using in the past, any
medication that they currently are using.
Here, take a look.
Basically, it's just to try and make sure that we don't get
another Lisa has it worked oh touch wood so far yes I keep a
copy of this hmm I wonder how much importance they actually
give to this test and what are they doing that's so
disturbing anyway where are they doing that's so disturbing
the aptitude test Alice do Alice do you some disturbing
techniques.
Incident prompted them to introduce an aptitude test.
Huh.
Alright.
Thank you.
Probably be back later.
Bye-bye.
Now I have to ask literally everyone in town about this.
But before I do.
Yep.
Okay.
Let's head to everybody's homes.
I have a single question for you.
I've learned something and I must ask you immediately before
I gather any other information.
Have you ever heard about there being devil worship at
Atlas?
Devil worship?
No.
Definitely not.
Who said that?
It's just something I heard.
Okay, thanks.
Yeah, we must ask the entire population.
That's it for the time being.
Thank you.
Simon, tell me about this aptitude test.
I know you took it.
Did you do a test before you started at Atlas?
yeah yeah um it was all just questions about okay if i had
any illnesses or mental health problems stuff like that you
know but they didn't actually ask for any proof so i could
have lied through your teeth on that one don't think they
actually checked interesting i have nothing wrong with my
brain and i definitely was not diagnosed with a parasite
that controls my right arm.
Thank you.
Probably be back later.
Nope.
In fact, don't even check because you won't find anything.
Don't even check.
Revolver.
I do not have a spirit in my brain.
A few more questions.
Guys, I have to go to the little ghosty's room soon.
Do you know anything about this?
It's the aptitude test, isn't it, for Atlas?
What do you want to know?
Do you know why it was introduced?
I think they had some trouble with some unsuitable students.
I suppose you have to be careful who you work with.
That's it.
That's all.
all for the moment.
Thank you.
Oh my goodness.
I think this is my biggest, like, uh, my biggest complaint
about this game so far is I got one thing.
Okay, time to ask.
At least there's not a huge cast of characters.
You know what I mean?
A few more questions, if you don't mind.
Can you ask them about Lisa?
Oh, you're right.
I don't think I've been asking them about Lisa's accusation.
Ah!
Forgetting!
Can you tell me a bit about this please it's the Atlas
attitude but the story itself is really fascinating does it
test exactly it's a test to we introduced to make sure that
any students didn't have any major personality problems
skeletons in the cupboard another lap around we introduced
it because we had a little bit of a problem with one of the
students Lisa you are well informed and what do you think it
was that disturbed her?
I believe that the course proved to be too demanding for
her.
We discovered that she had one or two psychological
problems.
One or two.
And did you change anything else on the course apart from
introducing the test?
We increased the entrance age to 21.
That wasn't much but it's about the only thing we could do.
We didn't want another Lisa, we didn't want students turning
around and suing us, did we?
Yeah, I love Paul so much.
He's so...
Like, he is such a character.
It's so awesome.
Like, he's such a good character.
Uh, raise the course entrance to 21.
Why do I feel like that's not true?
How old were you, Lisa?
Oh, wait, but she had a drinking problem.
Or, I mean, not Lisa, Kate.
So, I guess she would be.
Well, I mean, you don't have to be 21 to drink in The UK
though, no?
Wasn't someone in the course 20?
You have to be 18.
But still, there's no contradiction here.
I'm just going through real quick.
later on if that's okay what age do you need to have a bike
so true all right let's we'll still go down to our good
friend James can we go to this lady anymore no okay
18 should be the legal age to buy consume should be 16 oh
okay a couple more questions if that's okay
Lisa's accusation.
Do you know anyone who is interested in or involved with
devil worship?
Have you met Lisa?
Which Lisa are you talking about?
Mad Lisa lives on her own, doesn't like mirrors.
Okay, that's a lot coming from you.
You can't look at yourself in the mirror without seeing
ghosts.
You've got problems, don't you think?
How do you know her?
She came to the farm for some eggs a couple of times.
We're talking to her once, that's all.
And what did she tell you?
much except she thought the devil was after her what did you
tell her told her the devil needs a good reason to be after
you oh she was just like most people really blind to herself
except she's more extreme that's all madness is being blind
to yourself what I'm sure that helped James Lisa had visited
the farm a few times as Lisa thought the double I can't
believe he called her mad Lisa like says you James wouldn't
know about the aptitude test are we okay that's it for now
oh my god so I thought I was coming to him for two questions
and in the end it really was only one punished Lisa now we
have to go back to everybody else
Don't worry, you'll be back.
Oh, absolutely.
Dingling.
Okay, the accusations.
Have you ever come across anyone interested in or involved
with the occult?
As in black magic.
The occult, the occult, the occult.
The occult.
Atlas don't use occult techniques or anything like that.
Atlas, not unless Ryan's got a secret he's not telling me
about.
Why, he's been talking.
just a line of inquiry okay thanks on the upside he said
more than nope that's so true Yakult Yakult my tummy has
been kind of bothering me lately so I wanted to get some
Yakult and then I didn't read and I accidentally got Calpico
it was like the same bottle and everything I
Thank you, probably be back later.
What's the difference?
I don't think the Calpico has like the...
The...
Lactus...
Lact...
KCI Sherot...
Lactus Basilis...
KCI Sherota...
That...
That Yakult...
Has.
Lactus...
KCI Sherota...
probiotics no no Lactobacillus KCI Sheroda all
yogurts have some probiotics it's all good but it does it's
not advertised as that I don't even know if Calpico is a is
a yogurt drink actually not sure
My Sharona!
Emma.
I'm coming through your window.
Have you ever heard about there being devil worship at
Atlas?
My game is glitching again.
Devil worship?
Oh, it's stuttering, it's stuttering.
Definitely not.
Who's that?
It's just something I heard.
Okay, thanks.
Never heard of devil worship at Atlas.
Thank you.
Probably be back later.
My Sharona?
My Sharona!
about devil worship devil worship where at Atlas devil
worship at Atlas no there's none of that yes none of that
that's all for the moment thank you okay call
the chief for an update haven't asked Emma about the Atlas
episode thank you just a few more questions if you don't
mind Gosh, you really started losing...
Have you seen one of these before?
Um, no, not this one exactly, but we had to fill something
similar in on the first night at Atlas.
One of those aptitude tests, you know, fitness and stuff
like that.
So it's different?
Okay.
Be back later on, if that's okay.
Be back later!
Okay, let's go to it.
Talk to the chief.
Wow, why'd they change it?
Chief!
Chief, I got mugged!
That was like three hours ago.
Make it interesting, Jank.
Chief, I finally saw a bit of what goes on at Atlas.
I walked in on a meeting.
Very strange.
There were several students sitting around a fire taking it
in turns to burn handmade woolen dolls.
Emma was at Third Eye and Atlas, yeah.
Ryan had an for it as did Simon he claimed it was all about
burning your past or something actually Simon told me
something interesting he said they also use auto hypnosis on
the course oh what's that self hypnosis hypnotizing yourself
apparently that may have been what disturbed Lisa so much is
it dangerous well not in theory nobody I've spoken to seems
to think so well if it disturbs Lisa so much then it can't
be all that safe I suppose it depends on your state to begin
with but i look into it okay keep it up jacks always do
chief always do oh very funny very funny bye-bye i love the
chief i love the chief he's so funny all right there must be
a contradiction somewhere one
second wait chief call number six press here seven times to
see a cheat
Wait, what?!
That's how you see the cheese!
Wait, that's so funny!
I guess because...
Oh my...
I'm just so curious about it.
I'm just...
I think it's so funny.
Okay, so the auto hypnosis isn't dangerous and suggested
looking into it further.
Oh gosh, I'm like thinking of all the people with the auto
hit.
No, okay.
Why are you guys saying six, seven?
Oh, because it's clue six.
Press seven.
Oh my god.
Wait, one?
Oh!
This is your first cheat.
this is your first oh my god it added it to my cheats on
here it's so funny i know it's why is it in green okay paul
claims it's impossible to be hurt or damaged in any way by
hypnosis but he also said lisa couldn't handle the
techniques but didn't most of these techniques involve
hypnosis
I'm thinking about that.
I don't think I would have clocked that at all.
I gotta lock in.
This game was originally designed for the Amazon Fire Stick.
That's why the controls are a little strange.
What?
That's crazy.
Huh.
At least I couldn't handle the course techniques.
But impossible to be hurt or damaged.
Uh-huh.
me that.
No one told me that.
So nobody has ever been affected by auto-hypnosis.
I was just curious what would happen.
Except Lisa.
Hypnosis wasn't the problem, Inspector.
Lisa was the problem with Lisa.
That's why we introduced the test.
But the hypnosis was the trigger, wasn't it?
Lisa arrived on the course believing we were all devil
worshippers.
She was nuts to start with.
We didn't make her like that.
Well, as far as I can tell, Paul, you've had one student
accuse you of devil worship and two others commit suicide
yeah some of your students aren't having a very good time on
this course are they nonsense Kate was enjoying every minute
of it she couldn't get enough of it really she was full of
the joys of life bubbly confident flirty with whom you mean
with whom with whom pretty much everybody including me as I
remember really and did you respond with students,
inspector, company, policy.
Oh, shut up.
Shut up.
Interesting admission that Kate flirted with him.
There's no way Paul would have turned down an opportunity
like that.
Wait, how do I...
How do I call him out for not getting in...
What's tried to date Emma?
Avoids relationships with students.
Excuse me?
So you avoid relationships with students except for Emma,
who you tried to date.
Oh, come on, Inspector, that was a long time ago.
And what about Kate Vine?
Did you try to date her or not?
Oh, don't be so ridiculous, Inspector.
Kate was an exceptionally clever girl.
Clever girl.
She knew exactly what she wanted, and she knew how to get
it.
You mean that Kate approached you?
It wouldn't surprise me if she was playing everyone in the
group.
Kate had more enemies than you'd think.
She was a very, very manipulative young woman.
Oh!
10, 10 p.m.
10 o'clock, it's getting late.
I'm gonna have to pick up the pace if I'm gonna solve this
by midnight.
Arbitrary deadline of midnight for some reason.
Oh no, oh no, oh no!
Did we get anything new from that?
No.
Alright.
I'm consulting the light bulb.
Wonder who's in the pub.
Okay.
Oh.
I really don't think it's my place, darling.
They're in the restaurant!
I just don't want to tell tales.
Tell him about Scythe.
You know what happens when you don't, as I say.
Oh.
Ah!
So it's going to be that kind of evening, is it?
If you play, you can't, right?
Only if you deal.
Problems.
Hello, Inspector.
See you later.
You
know, I thought it was that kind of relationship, and it
absolutely is.
It absolutely is.
I can't believe it.
Um...
Do I want to go to the restaurant?
They left and, uh...
I can't stop looking at the arm in the mirror.
Watch it, watch it like...
Flex a little bit and then disappear.
Shoo!
I can't stop looking at it.
What's...
Did I get anything new?
What did Ryan take from that cupboard?
Yeah, that's what I was wondering.
But how do I...
Is he back at Atlas?
Like, how do I go find that?
Is he behind the pub?
Are you waiting back here?
Maybe...
Behind his home?
It's so blue.
It's soul blue Dabadi double die Looked like a Oh was there
a magnifying glass?
Oh my gosh I didn't even see it, thank you guys Back to the
pub
I was too distracted by the arm What is that?
Pills here Whirlmorph liquid Well isn't that interesting
what is a rough cut white cube what kind of cube is it so
what are they Rebecca's prescriptions prescriptions made out
to Rebecca were found in a cupboard in the pub this is
starting to feel oh sugar that doesn't feel I mean I know
we're investigating but that feels like bordering legality
so Rebecca what pills What do you take?
What is your prescription?
The cupboard downstairs.
There's a lot of unopened stuff in it.
Is that?
Prescriptions made out to you.
Oh, they're just spare painkillers.
The chemist always gives us too many as a friend of the
family.
Oh, that's not good either.
He's giving you too much morphine?
Is that what it is?
But...
Wasn't it like an or-or-o-morpho or something?
That's not good.
Thank you.
Probably be back later.
Uh-huh.
Yeah, that doesn't sound legal at all.
Alright, time to ask everybody about Rebecca's prescription
in town.
Almost.
It's literally morphine.
What the hell?
What's going on?
is to go the bike oh oh wow hello simon he's the most
oblivious man on earth
the bike just pickpocketed him probably nothing important
but at this stage i need all the clues i can get didn't
kate have morphine in her system she did
She did.
Oh my god, you're right, I forgot that detail.
Drop the key ring.
Send Bernard de Minson.
Oh, look at the dog.
Business tech was, business, business tech, sorry, Aztec.
Sorry, that's how my brain works.
Business card was dropped by Simon on the way into his
house.
Hmm.
Uh, let's go inside.
Simon?
I'm knocking for Simon.
A few more questions, please.
Business tech.
It's unlikely Simon.
Yeah, it's unlikely anybody would know about that.
I think you dropped this outside.
Someone you know.
Oh, this is just from some IT guy there.
I don't need it.
I had a code on the back.
I noticed some numbers.
the back do you need these i don't know what is it uh one
nine zero five oh yeah yeah that's just that's just a pin
for something it's okay i can remember it so not an official
savings account no no it's uh it's not important suspicious
suspicious wrote his pin on the back of the card
what's this is this yours yeah that's from my keys where did
you find that just outside right oh it must have come off
when Nathan dropped my keys off no uh he was borrowing my
car no it came up just now trusting yeah I suppose it is I
am I bet too trusting really it's a new car as well no I
just can't why are you giving it back to him it's yours
What about your...
No.
Aha.
So the bike's the only way you can get to work, yes?
Yeah.
What's wrong with the car?
No, I can't drive the car yet, can I?
I don't have my license.
Right.
I got a windfall from an insurance payout.
Just figured I'd buy something sensible with it straight
away instead of wasting the money.
What was the insurance payout?
are you gonna buy a depreciating car we got stolen down at
that you can't drive and also lend to others well they
didn't break in i think they just a car that depreciates in
value the laptop was in a storeroom but i think the lock was
broken that's what you think is taking their security very
seriously a better use of the money after that i think i'll
check in anyway this has been a very nice laptop to be able
to buy a car with the insurance or a very cheap car Might
have to have a talk with Ryan about his security measures.
Wait, I missed that.
Hold on.
I missed that entire...
Because I was so caught up on the...
Wait, so he had a laptop stolen while attending a meeting at
Atlas?
And he used that money to buy a car?
Usually you can replay them, but this one is not allowing me
to.
For some reason.
Oh, maybe if I do the contradiction again.
Oh, wait.
No, actually, I don't think...
I don't think it'll even let me.
Where's the... Oh, wait.
Oh, wait, never mind.
Sorry.
Oh!
Wait, no, I'm gonna rewatch it.
Laptop stolen from a storeroom.
Owens a new car but doesn't have a license.
Okay, okay, that's fine, that's fine, that's fine.
You can view it again from the menu.
It's okay.
Sorry I was talking over it.
That's it for the time being.
Thank you.
how we how i would like to see the car oh i forgot to talk
to emma ask you a couple more things please do you know
about this have you seen this before this um nope sorry
never heard of him emma i don't trust you i don't trust you
one bit what do you know about this this what do you know
This is Simon's.
I bought this from Rural Holiday.
Has he lost it?
Beloved Minto.
I can't keep anything.
I hope this ends with Emma breaking up with Simon and moving
far, far away from this place.
It's clearly not good for her.
Did you know about Simon's laptop being stolen?
Yeah, because it had all my college work on it, which I
hadn't backed up or saved.
Not that it mattered much, did buy a new one and Simon uses
it now when I let him yes Simon's laptop for college work
bought a new laptop for them both why didn't he buy a new
laptop
he decided to buy a car okay he bought a car he can't drive
instead of the laptop and then makes his girlfriend Buy a
laptop for the both of them?
I'm sorry, what?
I guess I mean she did use the Simon's laptop for her
college work, but what?
All Emma does is eat hot chip and lie.
It's true!
She eat hot chip and lie!
All girls do.
is eat hot chip and lie.
What does that make me, though?
I can't have spicy.
Oh, well, I'm a ghost, so I don't know.
Anyway, hold on.
I will be...
Probably be back later.
Right back with one more question to you all.
Ghost girl, don't eat hot chip and lie.
I I Um...
We'll go to the little ghosty's room.
I will be right back.
Um... back, baby.
One second.
I'm gonna...
That door's starting to hurt a little bit.
Okay.
Welcome back, welcome back!
Thank you!
Tadayima!
Thank you for all this super chan!
See you guys!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you!
Blue, blue, blue, blue, blue, blue.
Blow, blow, blow.
Okay.
Uh, what was the pin number?
Call the chief.
Things you haven't asked.
James, Rebecca, Ryan, Paul.
What was the pin?
Let's go back to Simon.
A few more questions, if you don't mind.
And see.
You think it's the pin to his laptop?
Well, let's see.
Hold on.
I'm looking at other things
Noah's bike is not locked Because it does not It kept
talking about having a broken lock
I'm just going over things
Emmer's guilt Minky is hot tube What?
I'm the hot tube
Okay, whatever.
That's all for the moment.
Thank you.
Call the chief.
And then go to everybody else around the town and ask them
about all the things in the business card and the thing.
And all this and that.
Blah, blah, blah.
Heblah, blah, blah.
Any names, Jax?
Chief, are you serious?
discovery at the pub chief apparently rebecca takes what i
think is a morphine how did you get sick in the past 30
minutes prescription in a cupboard at the pub what did you
say about that well i couldn't make her out to be honest but
she didn't admit it was morphine and i saw ryan taking
something from the cupboard too didn't see what it was
though it could have been the same thing we'll check it out
and get back to me will you certainly will speak later okay
bye-bye okay bye paul poisoned the chief who else will give
us It's on where to go!
Actually...
Oh, look!
No.
Guys.
Look at our progress percentage!
Look
at our progress percentage!
That jumped up like crazy, though.
We started at 30%.
I'll just let you guys remember that.
Anyway, resume.
Um...
The Brandon House.
Sorry, Mint, we gotta put you down.
A few more questions, if you don't mind.
It keeps happening to me, and I don't know why!
Do you know who this is?
Dean Hayfield, Aztec.
Sorry, never heard of it.
We have, uh, some...
Prisoner?
Does R-I-T.
guy no manners has never heard of the IT consultant has
their own IT guy a prisoner Phoebe and Vicky would be proud
of you seen this before anywhere no no period I'm in stolen
laptop now what's this about what do you know about Simon's
laptop being stolen from Atlas no I wasn't it what did you
do about it ryan paid a con man to install a complicated
cctv system at twice the price that it would probably have
cost seemed to do the trick though we haven't had a theft
since a con man not happy about the theft has installed cctv
system okay be back later on if that's okay be back later on
i had three things to ask you now all right down the street
to the farm abby farm you think he's got chickens it's
better a couple more questions if that's okay recognize this
at all yeah he fixed my laptop does he live locally i think
so don't think so i don't know doesn't uh that doesn't
concern me i don't care he fixed my laptop i don't know
anything else about him i don't even know how i found him i
just walked into the guy and he said i'll fix your laptop
uh-oh you know how i mentioned that i've been having issues
with my my ai o cooling in my pc
Now it just is flashing the Lee and Lee logo for some
reason.
Oh, it stopped flashing, but now I can still see it.
That shouldn't even be on.
Why is it showing that?
Huh.
Why do I always have computer problems?
Is it because I'm haunted?
Is it because of the EMFs?
I'm using up the energies.
A ghost in the AIO.
Call Aztec.
I need help.
I've seen this before.
Don't think so.
Okay.
Never seen it.
Unlikely James Manoa.
Okay, that's it for now.
I thought they were friends-ish.
The game's graphics are...
too good obviously uh this is unity 10 sneak peek it's only
a little uncanny sorry for jinx's uh facial expressions you
know a few more questions please thank you
electronic bit phantom yeah mouth
have you seen this before no okay nobody knows about this
this Aztec guy Dean Hayfield do you know anything about this
no sorry no no no oh my god Rebecca's useless Rebecca you're
useless to me to Atlas no okay the The screen went
completely black now.
What's wrong with my computer?
Jank's facial animations are set to 200%, it's true!
Ask you a couple more things, please.
Yeah, I hope it's just the screen.
I hope the...
It's actually still cooling, you know.
Do you know what the medicine in the cupboard at the pub is
for?
You'd better ask Rebecca about that.
I'm not exactly sure what's in there.
She tends to keep her aware as under lock and key.
Do you know our wedding night was quite a surprise.
Also if she keeps herself under lock and key how was I able
to see it then?
But also why would you tell me that?
Know anything about this?
What does that have to do with anything?
No I don't.
I'm sorry.
We have our own IT chap.
Lovely chap in fact.
Fat and sweaty.
it's like a double act doesn't it what does that mean what
does that mean what do you mean have you seen this before no
sorry nobody has seen this before either what happened with
simon's laptop were you at atlas when simon's laptop was
stolen oh i believe i was yes he was taken from the
storeroom in the hallway.
Was it ever recovered?
No, we didn't catch anyone.
We're quite exposed out here.
Somebody just wandered along the lane, seen into the
storeroom.
It's not particularly secure.
They could have been in and out within minutes.
That's why we advise people to keep their valuables with
them.
You can't be too careful these days, Inspector.
It was one of those risks that you guys, that you guys say
you should do.
You know?
The risks.
to steal from students.
Maybe you can actually steal from students.
The risks.
Yeah.
Advises students to keep valuables with them.
Thank you.
Probably be back later.
Is there anyone I forgot?
The pin.
for the card
click here to see oh wow look at that wait this is so handy
wait this is so handy put the pin on the back of the card we
misunderstood him he hasn't been on the same drink the whole
time he's got to be a few drinks in
wouldn't be that I don't know what the pen could be.
I figured it would be for the laptop, but it wouldn't let me
press him on that.
And also...
Yeah, I haven't seen anything like a laptop.
And also, I can't flip the card.
I think I'd have to go to... Okay.
Let's think of a place where we saw four numbers.
I don't know.
Wait.
Is it something in here?
It did look like 1905, didn't it?
Was it in the drawer?
No.
I'm thinking, I'm thinking, where would the pen be used?
Hmm.
But there's another thing in the woods to use the pen on.
Let's go!
We'll try it!
In the clearing, there's a mysterious safe.
I was just dropped there.
I'm just trying to think.
I'm really trying to think.
Oh, whoops.
Uh.
Gotta be an atlas.
But we've looked at everything, though.
I feel like we looked at everything.
Okay, let's go back in.
Into the atrium.
Into the door on the right.
I will go back into the...
Hold on.
Are there any new magnifying glasses?
None that I saw.
But it's also...
I wish it was like a different color.
Because it's hard to see it.
Uh...
We'll try it here.
No.
Maybe I need to talk to someone.
I think the game would tell us if we needed to.
Can we use it at the phone?
Check the farm in a while.
Yeah, we could try that.
I'm really at a loss.
With this one.
The post office, we can't go in.
Like, it just won't let us go in.
Didn't Jank say you should check out the Alice Warehouse
where the laptop got stolen from?
Is there a way to get to it?
The garage?
We'll just check everything right now.
You're stepping!
Nope.
Guys, I've already exhausted all options with Ryan and,
like, talking to people.
Okay.
Like if usually the little thing will tell me where to use
the or tell me what I'm missing the little light bulb and
it's only telling me to do the the pin
Even if there's a contradiction I feel like it would tell me
No, there's no computer in Atlas
Just a few more questions if you don't mind
Do you want to cheat?
It...
No, not quite yet.
No, they're no combination locks.
I think you dropped this outside.
Someone you know.
Oh, this is just from some IT guy in there.
I don't need it.
Enough.
I noticed some numbers on the back.
Do you need these?
I don't know.
What is it?
One nine zero five?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, that's just a pin.
for something it's okay I can remember it so not an optional
savings account or anything no no it's it's not important
1905 that's all for the moment thank you I'm
at a loss I'm at a loss when
I go to the phone booth it's like an automatic scene.
I can't control anything in there.
It does seem like a combination lock.
Yeah.
The dad hated the IT guy, but the son liked him.
Is that a contradiction?
Basically the way contradictions work is you can only
contradict what the person said themselves.
So if the dad says something, you can't use what he said
against what The sunset.
I feel like it's the pin to the laptop.
But we don't know where the laptop is to use it.
Like, I'm just kind of like...
I don't know.
And let me look in, like, their garage again or something.
The garage.
Janks has already used the remote control lock here.
Okay, just kidding.
I would like a hint.
If anybody...
Nose.
The pub?
Go talk to Rebecca.
Everybody's giving me conflicting answers.
I have no idea.
Ask about a few more things, please.
Doesn't take any drugs or medicine.
Rebecca's prescription painkillers.
So, you don't take any medicines except for prescription
painkillers.
Well, they're not actually for me, they're Ryan's.
For some reason, the chemist always makes them out to my
name.
That's weird.
He's an old gentleman.
Does Ryan need prescription painkillers?
Yes, he's got arthritis.
Really?
He's young to suffer from that, isn't he?
He doesn't have it badly.
but he does need medication from time to time.
What medicine is it?
I can tell you to be honest.
Ryan will know.
Ryan's the one using the prescriptions.
I think I might have a word with him.
Work out exactly what this medicine is.
The cane is diabolical.
What?
Be back later on if that's okay.
Oh my god.
The game did trick us.
okay I'll have to be a little bit more vigilant then oh I
forgot about her saying that to begin with that she doesn't
take the okay a couple
more questions if that's okay yeah why you have arthritis
about your arthritis oh you found out about that well yes
I'm old before my time that's very unlucky to have it so
young yeah well I take a lot from life, Inspector.
And sometimes life likes to give you a little bit back.
I mean, it's not too bad.
It's not too debilitating.
It's mainly, uh, some in my right hand, some in my left
hand.
It's not particularly a problem.
Uh, it makes it difficult to hold small things there.
What do you take for it?
I, uh, get a prescription painkiller.
How often do you need that?
Not often.
As and when, as and when.
I keep some here.
I keep some at home.
It's not a problem.
You don't allow things at Atlas.
You don't even allow anything.
Doesn't keep many medicines on site due to insurance
restrictions.
So, you don't keep any medicines on site at Atlas.
No.
Except your prescription painkillers.
Well, these are not available to the students.
But they are kept on site.
Yes, but they're locked away.
They're kept in the storeroom.
Nobody would have access to them.
You're sure about that?
It makes it hard to hold things.
Absolutely sure.
What are the painkillers, Ryan?
Well, they're painkillers.
Just painkillers.
Normal painkillers.
Paracetamol.
Codeine.
Morphine.
Well, all right.
They're morphine tablets, yes.
Oh, really?
Oh, come on, Inspector.
I know what you're thinking, but there's no way Kate could
have had access to them.
Because they're in the storeroom.
Well, not just that.
She wouldn't have even known about them, or where they were.
Sure about that.
Yes.
So it is morphine Ryan's taking.
The pieces are starting to come together.
Starting to come together.
Now I just have to work out how Kate got hold of it.
If it was Ryan's morphine she got hold of, of course.
Thank you.
Can we go to the store?
Is that where the code is for, I wonder, maybe?
Can we go to the storeroom?
Can I go to the storeroom?
Can you let me in the storeroom?
Can I enter the storeroom?
Is that the storeroom?
This reaction was Suss AF.
I know, I know.
Light arthritis does not need morphine.
Morphine is like crazy.
Columbo?
No, minto.
One more thing.
Yeah, wasn't the laptop stolen from the storeroom?
Exactly!
Let me end the storeroom, please!
Is it out here?
Can I access it from here?
I think I need to look into the storeroom.
No!
How do I find the storeroom?
I'm looking again.
That's the chief.
Things you have asked, okay.
It's so invasive.
Did you know that...
That...
That Ryan has arthritis?
Like, why do they... Why do I need to ask them about that?
It's kind of invasive, no?
Let me in that storeroom.
Let me in the storeroom.
Everything is...
Everything... All the answers are in the storeroom!
Oh, I know it.
A few more questions, please.
Contradict him on the storeroom being secure.
Yeah, I will.
I'll go back.
Did you know about Ryan Rand's arthritis?
Arthritis?
I didn't think Ryan had arthritis.
I didn't know about Ryan's arthritis.
That's it for the time being.
Thank you.
Did you know about Ryan's arthritis?
Ryan?
He's got arthritis.
Apparently.
No, I didn't know.
I had no to see him any problems.
He's got... he's got arthritis?
Oh my god.
I guess it is.
It is kind of shocking because he's so young.
Just airing out his...
Did you know that he has arthritis?
Just thought I'd tell you.
Oh, you didn't know?
Okay.
That's fine.
You know, I just thought I'd mention it.
Are we Jenks or Nancy Drew?
How long?
Oh, whoops.
I meant to go to the front.
how long do we have uh it's 10 p.m in the game and also in
for me and we have until midnight ask you a couple more
things please when did ryan begin to suffer from arthritis
ryan doesn't suffer from arthritis really the only thing
that ryan suffers from is a pathetic inability to deal with
any kind of discomfort he pulled his back sometime last year
since then he's going around telling everybody he suffers
from arthritis.
I thought he had medication for it.
For his back?
Oh, he only has medication because his GP, who is almost as
dysfunctional as he is, keeps prescribing it for him.
So you don't believe he really has arthritis?
Not at all.
Can you like get high on morphine?
Can you get addicted to morphine?
That's all for the moment.
Thank you.
Oh, you can.
Oh, super fast?
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, wait.
I think I meant to ask him.
Or wait.
Did I tell him?
Okay, never mind.
Yeah, he told us about the CCTV.
That's why it's illegal if not prescribed.
Oh.
They call it the Ryan Epidemic.
Ryan is...
Is...
That's...
He's...
What if he's, like, dealing morphine to people in the
village?
Heroin is just refined morphine?
I didn't know.
A few more questions, if you don't mind.
What?
He wouldn't know about his arthritis.
Oh, that's it for now.
At least we have the...
The hindsight to think that.
Opium, morphine, heroin, basically.
Oh.
Not a Satanist, just a drug dealer.
Now, how boring would that be?
Come on, I hope that they're summoning devils.
Please, please be summoning demons and the devils and
everything.
Please don't be a drug dealer.
That's so boring.
Come on.
What if when he disappears, it's because he has to cook?
Well, I'm not going to ask.
How do you make it?
Because I was going to be like, what if the ritual is
somehow involving the morphine?
They get the impressionable young college students to get
addicted to the morphine.
The true demon was addiction.
It's becoming too real.
What did I forget?
Oh, let's go.
I press him.
About the storage.
Into the atrium.
A couple more questions if that's okay.
All right.
Keeps the morphine in a secure room, storeroom at Atlas.
Storeroom isn't particularly secure.
Aha.
So the storeroom isn't particularly secure, yet you...
keep your morphine tablets in there.
I thought you said no one could get access to the morphine,
but they could quite easily, couldn't they, Ryan?
I didn't mean that store room.
I meant a different store room.
I kicked them in there.
Okay, so where was it locked up?
It's upstairs.
It's got a combination lock on it.
Nobody could have access to it except me and dad.
Nobody.
I might have a look at that if you don't mind.
Don't mind at all.
room, I see.
Well, I might have a look around for that.
See how secure and combination locked it really is.
A combination, you say?
I kind of wish it... Oh, now we can finally go upstairs.
How exciting!
A new area!
I almost wish he was just like, 1905.
And Ryan be like, what do you mean by that?
And he's like, 1905.
I know your combination.
Free morphine!
Oh, he's running up them stairs look
how easy it was welcome to the mirror room this exercise is
all about identifying the difference between the image one
presents to the world and one's real self which lies deep in
our unconscious as you move through the network of mirrors
practice seeing yourself as a stranger the more you separate
from your persona the more aware you will become your true
desires and ambitions chant with us i am free from my image
i am free from my past i am free from myself i am free from
my image i am free from my past i am free from myself i am
free from my image i am free from my past i am free from
myself i okay this exercise involves the use of liberation
masks you have now completed module one module two covers
boundary testing threshold testing and extreme testing
extreme testing carefully before attempting the module i
wish to leave the mirror room
I wish to leave the mirror room.
We are losing Minto.
I'm not Minto.
I don't know who I am.
I freed myself from that persona.
I am now.
Binto.
My original character.
A few more questions.
Yeah, where's the morphine in there?
What the hell was that?
Can you tell me what you know about the mirror what you know
about it oh you found that then hmm well it's very similar
to the costumes inspector it's designed to help the students
look at themselves differently and what do you do with the
mirrors you look at yourself inspector you look at yourself
until you start seeing yourself as as others do and you
don't see yourself as as you do anymore it really the idea
is that you can yourself eventually in any way you wish.
This is such a mumbo-jumbo-jumbo.
To make sure you're not distracted, that's all.
How often is it used?
Not often.
A few times a month.
Some students find it useful.
Sometimes.
I see.
The room is locked so students aren't distracted.
Like...
Where is the mumbo-jumbo?
Not because I want some.
I have freed myself from chat.
Oh, no!
Hold on.
Let's go back to the scrying mirror and see what he said
about that.
Okay.
scry me a river let's
go ask some other people about the mirror room thank you
probably be back later I'm afraid of Rebecca's response I'm
afraid of what she has done in the mirror room with Ryan I
am afraid of it ask you a couple more things please what is
this do you know about the mirror room I'm gonna grab a bag
of chippy's yeah what's it useful well it's mainly for the
auto hypnosis module you go in and you stare into the mirror
and you go into a trance then when you're ready you come
back out so you just go in whenever you want to oh no
there's certain times when you're allowed in and only they
know the combinations anyway so you can't really get in but
you don't know the combination no you don't know the
combination Yes.
So you didn't know the combination to the locked mirror
room?
No.
Except...
You'd written it down, hadn't you?
This is the combination to the mirror room, Simon, that you
wrote.
It isn't a pin.
It's a combination.
Yeah.
You see, this sort of thing makes me suspicious, Simon.
What were you doing in there that you didn't want to do?
anyone including me to find out it's just part of the course
isn't it I just I just wanted to go in there when I was
ready on your own you didn't give a number to anyone else no
Simon there was morphine kept in why was there more to play
the part in Kate Vine's death did Kate have the number yes
okay we both went in together we were trying to our outdo
each other we we both try to morphine what do you mean
trying to outdo it's part of the course to see how far you
can push yourself to see if you can do something you
wouldn't normally do like morphine a few months ago how
often did you try it only that once I'd never do it again
right I don't know sorry I Oh!
11 p.m.
That's how Kate got the morphine.
But what exactly does this testing involve?
Could this have been what killed Kate?
Uh-oh.
Just an hour left to solve this thing.
Uh-oh!
Morphine contest!
Pam freely, back on my own free will.
Yay!
Welcome back to Argo.
I definitely did not threaten you to come back at all.
Hi, Minto!
Hello, secret sir.
Thank you for 11 months!
Oh man, wait, let's see.
81%!
Oh my god!
Ooh, everything's picking up, everything's picking up.
Into the pub.
Tell me, Rebecca.
Tell me.
What do you know?
Just a few more questions, if you don't mind.
About the mirror room.
Do you know anything about a locked room at Atlas with
mirrors in it?
Not at the top of my head.
No, I think that's a question for Ryan.
I see.
Thank you.
Probably be back later.
Paul.
Your...
It's getting so dark.
Wait, it's so funny because it's 11pm?
But it's like...
So blue.
Ask about a few more things, please.
Can you tell me about the room with the mirrors at Atlas,
the one with the combination lock?
How did you get in there?
I was given the code for the combination.
By right?
Well, nobody else is allowed to know the code, are they?
And not in theory.
So how is the room used on the course then?
It's a meditation room where the students can reflect on
themselves, literally.
And what about the CD?
That helps too, it's part of the program.
So you send the students into the room, they put the CD on,
they stare into the mirrors.
And how long does this last for?
Until the CD finishes or they fall asleep, what else would
you like to know?
Fall asleep!
I mean, so neat room you got there, what's with all the
mirrors?
Why'd you lock the door?
Wait!
Now they fall asleep from the morphine!
Um...
in theory
okay there has to be a contradiction somewhere I'm gonna see
if we can call the chief too real quick since it's now 11 p
.m.
chief I'm calling you late into the night oh what's
happening
what is this Amazon delivery at 11 p.m.
I'm a bald man.
Hmm.
Suspicious.
Chief.
Why is it so blue?
Because it's dark out.
It's nighttime.
This is what happens in the UK.
Okay.
Let's go.
Let's go talk to him.
Hey, what the, what, what'd you get there?
What'd you get there?
A couple more questions if that's okay.
Oh, we're not going to ask.
Wait, we're not going to ask about that?
Okay.
Be back later on, if that's okay.
Maybe he put it up in the garden.
There's just a huge blue light.
That they put over the sun.
Like, oh my god, it's so blue.
It's so blue.
Dabadi, dabadar.
Oh!
What does that say?
What the heck was...
So James is interested in poppy pods, is he?
Poppy pods.
I think he's got some explaining to do.
What the heck is a poppy pod?
What?
This box of dense it's...
checkies from the side.
What's a poppy pod?
That's a poor opium!
I don't... Oh my gosh, you guys are learning.
I don't know anything about drugs at all.
I know.
I would be the worst detective.
I'd be like, hmm, he's gardening.
I don't know anything.
Do you want questions please?
What's the box of poppy pods?
What can you tell me about several boxes of dried poppy pods
in the greenhouse back there?
Feel free to take some if you want.
What are they for, James?
Decoration, right.
Decoration.
It's a big market for them among the over 70s.
So what are you doing with them?
Selling them to grannies.
Okay, James, let's just cut to the chase.
Are you extracting opium from them?
them me i can honestly say i've never done anything like
that inspector sure about that scouts on her and who was the
guy delivering them a friend she only knows what she's like
someone gave them to him he asked me if i wanted them that i
said i'd have a look i can tell you all about you just
thought you'd have a look no particular reason i'm a plant
scientist that's what i do have you ever sold them to anyone
else i only got them a few minutes ago in the past you know
kate's body had opium in the blood when it was found no no i
didn't hey hey that's nothing to do with me ah see yeah
that's why we're questioning
never extracted anything from the pods we do know that he
was uh actually oh gosh i don't remember where it's at pods
from a friend who didn't want them years.
Poppy paws are used for decoration.
We already know that's a lie.
Thank you.
Ooh.
Dealing with opium is a classic British pastime.
The poppies.
Is that what they mean by poppy playtime?
No.
Haven't searched the woods for a while.
Ha ha ha ha.
okay but first we go inside ask you a couple more things
please what do you know about poppy pods poppy pods poppy
pods ever come across anyone selling them using them no no
yeah I guess we're gonna go look for where people are
growing thank you okay I'm sorry but it's very obviously
like a well used trail that's in the woods.
If I discover that someone is growing poppy pods, literally
off of the...
Literally off of, like, the path is going to be so stupid.
World's dumbest...
World's dumbest drug dealer ever.
Besides Walter White.
Well, now, I'm sorry.
He was not a drug dealer.
He was a drug maker.
A few more questions, if you don't mind.
What?
What do you know about poppy pods?
Go on.
Have you ever come across anyone trying to sell them or
anything like that?
Maybe even in here.
And not that I remember.
She's so sexy.
Dang.
Thank you.
Probably be back later.
We'll go to...
We'll ask everybody first and then we'll...
Oh my god, it's so dark.
And then we'll go to the woods.
Emma, it's 11 p.m.
and I'm knocking on your window.
I'm crawling through your window at 11 p.m.
It's so bright inside.
Have you ever known of anyone selling dried poppy pods?
Poppy pods?
Um, don't think so.
Isn't that opium?
Yeah, she's a great actress.
It's okay.
Doesn't know anything about poppy pods.
Ah, that's all for the moment.
Thank you.
Isn't poppy what they laid in the...
Field in Wizard of Oz?
Poppies?
Did you ask her about the mirrors?
Oh, I don't think I did.
Be back later on, if that's okay.
Oh, it is!
Oh, poppy flowers.
Oh, yeah, I forgot to ask.
Thank you.
Do you know about the mirror room at Atlas?
The mirror room.
No, I heard about it, but I think it was only for the
students that were on the course.
Something like that.
Okay.
Okay, that's it for now.
Thank you.
Checks out, I think.
I remember what happened.
They fell asleep.
Yeah!
You're right.
Back then, was it known that, like, that, like, morphine was
a drug and had that kind of effect, I wonder.
Odd question.
Well, I mean, morphine has been around, but, like, you know
what I mean, like, it's like...
Poppy pods.
As in, for opium?
No.
though James didn't have opium tea once I think where did he
get it from I don't know I didn't ask James does his own
thing what does opium tea taste like I don't know I didn't
try it really I didn't want to risk it did I I went to
hospital once I had codeine and I went into anaphylactic
shock the doctors said it was um an opium derivative
apparently so whoa allergic to opiates
whoa didn't you make teas or whatever uh wait where does it
where does it say that
oh makes it uh tried selling it but only sold to james Oh,
right.
He took the morphine in the...
Yeah, why would he lie to me about that?
Wait, you don't have an allergy at all, you liar?
What the hell?
You and Kate took morphine in the mirror room.
That's what you said, isn't it?
Yep.
But you're allergic to opiates, Simon.
Opium.
You didn't take the morphine at all, did you?
Well, no.
No, I didn't.
Kate did though I thought you were trying to outdo each
other that was the point wasn't it what if you have an
allergy I mean we weren't trying to outdo each other as such
go on Ryan wanted me to test Kate to see how far she would
go to be prime candidate what candidate prime candidate it
means the best person in the group basically if they've been
caught saying like she's a very promising person's the
tester, it's me.
And the other person's the victim.
Well, it's not like that.
It's completely consensual.
It's just boundary testing.
Ryan wanted me to test Kate.
Because they thought she was the best student.
Well, maybe.
I don't know.
I just did what I was told, okay?
Except you decided to give her morphine to break the law.
I can't change that now, can I?
She didn't die of a morphine overdose, did she?
She died because she drowned.
But she drowned for reasons that aren't clear.
Oh!
Atlas seemed to have this all neatly worked out.
If Simon's telling the truth, Atlas are lighting the fuse
and then retiring to a safe distance, letting students test
themselves and push themselves to their limits while
avoiding all comeback.
Is this what happened to Kate?
How?
okay
uh thank you let's see if emma knows anything okay let's
just go back real quick the little crown is so cute do you
know what a prime candidate is at atlas yes it's um what
every student wants to be it's the best student you get a
great high pay job afterwards what i don't think that really
happens though did you know anyone in the running to be
prime candidate leon like simon i don't think they picked
Simon, to be honest.
Well, he's got too many morals, and you can't help both at
Atlas.
Oh.
He also has an allergy to opium.
You can't have that at Atlas either, I guess.
Oh, my gosh.
What the hell?
Thank you.
Probably be back later.
Wow.
Ooh.
Oh,
gosh, we're going to ask lots of things about Prime
Candidates and such.
I can't believe they're still letting me into their home at
11 p.m.
though.
Don't you guys sleep?
Oh, it is Friday.
A couple more questions, if that's okay.
Know anything about Poppy Pods?
Poppy Pods?
Come across anyone selling them or anything?
Poppy Pods.
or don't tell anyone, Inspector, but I hear that you can
make opium out of those.
Is this just common knowledge?
It doesn't matter.
Now, tell me what a prime candidate is.
You're learning a lot, aren't you, Inspector?
I think.
Prime candidates are simply the best students, the ones with
the most potential.
And what benefits do they get from that?
Well, they get the top job.
Which is?
Well, we have a deal with...
various multinationals.
We train students to be exceptional, truly exceptional.
Truly exceptional.
And they get a wonderful top job.
It seems very simple deal.
And how do you decide who the prime candidate is?
Have you test students?
No.
Did you ever say...
I need to watch more shows like Breaking Bad.
Do you test Kate, for instance?
Oh, you've actually been speaking to Simon, haven't you?
I really wouldn't trust anything that Simon Thompson says.
Do you know, he spent the best part of two months to
undermine Kate no no no no no no no Simon Thompson I really
isn't my place to speculate but if you're looking for
motives inspector he certainly had a few motives I uh more
than I what a motive to kill her do you mean now that's very
interesting inspector well that's up to you to decide what
other motive would it would you be implying whatever motive
would you be implying huh very very interesting that's all
for the moment thank Very, very interesting.
Let's go to the woods.
I want to see what's happening in the woods.
Into the woods.
They're turning on each other.
Yeah.
Into the woods.
The clearing.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Am I going to get mugged again?
Just keep pushing.
just keep pushing keep pushing keep pushing you can push it
all the way in tom if you want to
excellent tom excuse me someone care to tell me exactly
what's going on here don't come any closer that man needs a
doctor oh he doesn't why do you think bun's at pop i don't
need a doctor i'm fine wait hold on what is this test of
what what does it look like it's a threshold test a pain
threshold test i thought uh you were supposed to be good at
working things out inspector jenks how do you know my name
and so this would be for atlas would it kyle kyle you
disappear now it's not a good idea to talk to a police
inspector like that.
Do you want to make you?
It's okay, Tom.
Mr. Jenks won't be bothering us anymore.
Don't make any rush commitments.
Just push it in.
Push it in.
Kyle.
I love the day for night.
It's so glaringly bad.
Oops, somebody dropped their keys.
Well, well.
You really should take more care of your things, Ryan.
is your keys Kyle no
so that's threshold testing is it sticking a skewer through
your hand I could just ask Ryan or Paul directly about this
but I think I'll bide my time see what I can do with this
key fob first we have another car key fob interesting
interesting I once heard that If you are about to, like,
take a drug test for a job, you should not have a poppy
seeds.
It's making so much sense to me now because it can influence
your test.
Oh my god, I once heard that!
It's making so much sense to me now.
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh.
Because if you have just some, like, on a bun or something.
They'll be like...
Brain explosion!
Yeah!
That's why everything bagels are banned in Korea.
Is that true?
What?
Poppy seed bagels could give a positive.
Oh my gosh!
Wait!
But I like poppy...
Am I...
Am I getting high?
I eat everything beggles.
No, I'm going to go to jail.
She's the prime candidate.
At least I don't have an allergy.
I'm an addict.
Everything beggles.
Maybe don't admit this on.
tree oh my god they just sell this in stores i ate this as a
child i don't know actually i don't
now i've been dead for a while
you're just high on afterlife my ocean is addicted to bagels
that's my opium no Wait, uh, buh buh buh buh, buh.
We grab the car key fob.
To their house.
To behind their house.
To stealing their car.
Peep, peep.
That's right.
Good old Morphe and Mint.
She also eats poppy seeds.
She's a member of Yakult.
The whole cannibal thing.
What next?
Summoning demons!
Time out.
Oh, she admitted she was helping him.
Don't distill the bagels.
Bingo.
What have you been up to?
Be very interesting to see how he explains this one.
I also encourage everyone to join the Yakult Yakult, Yakult,
Kult Beware of dog I'm sorry, wait a second That's a
contradiction They don't have a dog
500 pounds for Kate Are dead victim Why was there a 500
pound K for Kate the Yap cult I'm going straight there baby
straight there more questions please yeah oh excuse me would
you like to explain what this is please Ryan 500 pounds
intended for Kate it fell out of your car I assume that's
your car on the driveway at brandon house i suppose so so
why were you going to give kate 500 pounds ryan it was just
a little incentive that's all just a little incentive not
very little ryan 500 pounds she was uh a very good student
we we heard that she was leaving we wanted to give her
something but you didn't well obviously not are you sure
there wasn't any other reason you might want to give her
this personal reason no well I'd like to keep hold of this
for a little while if you don't mind well don't consider it
a bribe will you inspector money meant as a little incentive
oh yeah okay hmm heard Kate wanted to leave Atlas no
ulterior reason for giving Kate the money
Do we have any like blackmail?
Anything that would be like, oh yeah, see ya.
I wonder if it was like Kate was gonna talk about Emma.
You know, like let that get out.
Maybe Kate was bribing him, not bribing, blackmailing him.
Later on, if that's okay.
I mean, that would make sense.
Not him blackmailing Kate.
Because if you're blackmailing her, why would you give her
money?
You know?
That's why they fought.
What was it that they fought about?
It was that, wasn't it?
Uh, but, but, but, but, but, okay, it's argument.
I had an affair with Ryan.
Kate wanted to blackmail Ryan over her affair.
Yeah!
Um, excuse me.
Ask you a couple more things, please.
I don't actually know if we can use that, though.
Let me see.
Um, the argument.
Yeah, we can't use that because that was what Emma's
response was.
Probably be back later.
Okay.
Hmm.
There was definitely something about no incentives.
Was there?
students aren't tested which we will definitely we will
definitely get that contradicted later
oh okay trying to see if maybe there is something about no
incentives okay
whatever it's too difficult looking through it.
Just a few more questions, if you don't mind.
Why is there no entry for that pain threshold test?
Jank said that he was going to hold on to it for later.
He didn't want to...
He didn't want to use it just right yet.
Wait.
Actually, go back to science.
Thank you.
Probably be back later.
Oh, yeah.
Simon told Jank's about pranking.
Okay.
That's all for the moment.
Thank you.
We're getting so far off track, I'm answering why Simon
didn't lock his bike.
I can't believe his bike came back at some point though.
Emma wouldn't...
Be back later on if that's okay.
All right.
85% done, guys.
We're so close.
We're so close!
Did you ask Ryan about Prime Canada?
Yeah.
We did.
Yeah, see, about, not, about, this was when he was just
like, you shouldn't trust Simon.
Simon is this and that, and Simon was trying to undermine
Kate.
Ask about a few more things, please.
The prime candidates.
Do you know what a prime candidate is?
At Atlas.
It's the best student.
And what does that mean?
It means they get a guaranteed job with a very good salary.
Well, that's the idea anyway.
but mostly they aren't up to it what happens then to get
sacked oh you just can't be in the club they get fired best
not to ask rebecca about the money for kate okay that's it
for now thank you that's crazy you just get kicked out
That's so stupid.
This cult sucks, man.
I know.
Oh, I keep going to the back, sorry.
A couple more questions, if that's okay.
What are prime candidates?
The best of the bunch.
The peaches.
Peaches.
And so what does it mean to be a prime candidate?
We have a special relationship with many major international
companies.
We provide them with our best students.
And they get an instant job.
And what do you get out of it?
Well, it's a little kickback.
It's just business, Inspector.
Business.
his kickback payment now why do you think ryan might want to
give kate a check for 500 pounds i really no idea where did
you find it just outside you better ask him you think ryan
was interested romantically in kate i know he has a weakness
for blondes but i didn't think it
Nah, just outside.
Yeah, it was just, it flew directly in the wind, from the
wind into my hand.
Thank you.
Probably be back later.
Blonde, but his wife is a Brunette.
And so, so is Emma.
I don't think he's in the blonde.
Wait, also...
net wait a second it's does that wait did he
can we not contradict that hold on we'll go back in a second
questions please we'll come back in a second for that um
that's very curious okay thank you probably be back later
I can't tell if it's a script error or not, to be honest.
That's what I'm wondering, if it's that or...
I'll ask you a couple more things, please.
I was interested in blondes.
Only met Kate if you...
I don't know.
How do you contradict this?
Maybe he was making a joke.
A script error in a mystery game.
Right, that's why I'm like...
Try it with Met with her.
No.
Only Met Kate a few times.
Like, I feel like if he's thinking of somebody else...
Paul, are you colorblind?
From where I'm from, blonde can mean woman.
Maybe that's why it's in like the quotes like this.
Blondes is like a term for females.
I wonder.
Women is my type.
Never heard of that.
I wonder.
I don't know.
I did both of these.
Only met her and spoke to her.
Neither of them worked.
I don't know.
honestly we don't have like anything else that i could
really use with kate involvement that's all for the moment
thank you baoba welcome to bamboo ship thank you i already
tried to saw her at a meeting it didn't work it didn't work
um i'm gonna call the chief and see if he has anything to
say
yeah i wish i could just use the id itself and like hello
hello very much so sir an interesting discovery in ryan's
car a check for 500 pounds from ryan made out to kate he
said it was an incentive apparently he'd heard she was
thinking about i was writing the ralph student i suppose uh
doesn't add up 500 pounds is a lot more than an incentive
checks you can buy questions in parliament for that kind of
money sounds pretty desperate.
Keep on a Ryan about it.
Yeah.
Oh, and play yourself another drink.
Another drink.
Thanks, Chief.
I'm having one.
Bye.
What the heck?
So we gotta go talk about the check more.
There must be a contradiction.
Alright, well, let me... I'm checking this.
You should call the Chief for an update.
I did.
Okay, cool.
A few more questions if you don't mind.
Okay, let's check my...
No ulterior reason.
We have to find something maybe about the affair.
You know?
Anything about the affair?
Did we ever press him on that?
I don't even know if we did.
Enjoyed the course.
Oh, that's true.
Heard Kate wanted to leave.
Oh, yeah, that's true.
No.
Hmm.
What about the friend's hair color?
Oh, she's brunette, too.
Emma, Emma is also brunette.
I don't think we've...
Ever asked or ever brought that up?
Rhyme candidates?
Hmm.
I don't know.
Try this.
No.
The only blonde is Emma's boyfriend.
Right!
Simon!
He's the blonde.
Wait.
He's interested in blondes.
Oh my god, it all makes sense!
It all makes sense!
The sass!
Oh my god!
Getting rid of Kate so that he could have Simon be the...
the prime student!
The cross-dressing!
Oh my god.
I'm kind of stuck here though
Not giving student bribes Did he say that though?
I thought I can't find it if he said that
Chief said get a drink Maybe that was a clue to go to the
bar Maybe
Contradiction of morphine being in the safe But Students
access to the safe room.
I think we've touched on that, but I could try.
Um, here...
Oh wait, um...
I don't think so, because it is a combination locked room.
I think it's okay.
Auto hypnosis?
There's so many things.
My gosh.
Ah!
Students are coerced or bribed!
There it is!
Thank you.
got money meant for his little incentive we'll try that one
instead okay oh my goodness thank you there
we go huh good job thank you guys so students aren't coerced
or bribed in any way except Kate I'm not sure what you mean
you said you were going to give Kate the 500 pounds as an
incentive that's coercion isn't I really don't think you
could call it coercion, Inspector.
What would you call it then?
It was an incentive.
That's all a little encouragement.
So how often do you use incentives?
Okay, incentive is probably the wrong word.
The money was just to see how Kate would respond.
It was part of her assessment.
Oh my God.
Everything's part of the assessment.
We have to assess students as they progress.
We don't use conventional methods like sitting an exam or
anything like that.
People pay for this course per session.
We have to know if they're committed or not.
So you're assessing their progress?
and testing their commitment yes we are we have to this is a
business not a charity commitment to the cult this is so
ryan's claiming the money was part of kate's assessment and
did this assessment also involve threshold testing i wonder
or was the money for something else wait where did that put
the okay here we go students pay per course per session give
kate the money to test test assess her
uh wait a second didn't he say though um students aren't
tested you said that yeah they don't test any yeah yeah yeah
well which one is it ryan do you test students or not well
some of them yes including kate yes why was she being tested
she was being tested because because we wanted to see if she
was good enough to become prime candidate okay so Kate was
in the running to be prime candidate yes and did you ask
Simon to test her yes I did but I didn't ask him to do
anything stupid he knew it was against course rules how far
did you ask him to push her I didn't ask him to push her I
asked him to test her there's a huge difference if Simon
decided to give her too much caffeine or morphine or
whatever that's his So if he did anything wrong, it was his
own responsibility.
He did it with his own mind and his own hand.
Oh, my God.
We had nothing to do with it.
It's midnight.
Midnight.
And still no suspect, unless you count everyone I've
interviewed.
It's no surprise that Ryan wants to avoid any suggestion of
being responsible for Kate's death.
But I wonder if the man protests just a little too much.
Yeah.
Oh, I think so, too.
Oh, 93%.
Alright, nice.
Okay, we will be able to beat this game today, guys.
I think so.
That was awesome.
That was like a true Phoenix Ride meltdown.
It was so good.
Alright, let me see.
Wonder what Paul thinks about prime candidates.
Also, some things you haven't asked.
What did I get?
Oh, Kate's prime status.
There we go.
I will get myself a drink in the pub.
We didn't tell him about Simon giving morphine to Kate.
Did we?
I don't think so.
That's a good point.
Yeah, because Simon told us that they would go, that they
went to the mirror room and did that.
And also, yeah, that's a good point.
A few more questions, if you don't mind.
Huh.
Did you know Kate Vine was a prime candidate?
No.
Be back later on if that's okay.
Let's go ask Paul.
Couple more questions if that's okay.
Simple no after riots crash out is amazing.
Oh, there we go.
Was Kate a prime candidate?
Well, as Ryan is probably already told you yes she was did
you ask simon to test her yes it's company policy leaders
don't get involved and it covers your back of course and
nobody knows the students better than they do inspector it's
much better to let them just work it out among themselves it
isn't very professional to force students to test each other
to the point where one of them gets killed paul we don't
force students to do anything that they don't want to do
inspector so you don't them into being tested no we don't
encourage anybody to hurt or offend anybody else here you
don't use threshold testing for instance no if simon
thompson went too far with kate that's his responsibility
not ours he's the one you should i think it's time to bring
out our wild card i don't trust him myself students not
encouraged to hurt each other don't use threshold testing
okay well we'll come back to that i suppose
clock, the T?
Yeah!
I feel like there's something here still, though.
Kate was being tested.
Leaders don't get involved.
Like, I feel like there's something.
The threshold testing, we don't have the thing for it.
I'm seeing if there's anything.
But it's like a...
Anything about, like, we don't test or we don't, you know,
we don't, uh, pressure and things like that, you know what I
mean?
That's what I'm going through.
I wonder if it's Atlas doesn't use scrying on the course.
But then there's a mirror.
Oh, you know what?
I'm just gonna try it.
Oh, oh, why did it disappear?
No, okay.
Scrolling, scrolling through everything.
Okay.
Okay, we'll have to come back for the threshold testing once
we're able to use that as a... I feel like that was our...
that was our uh...
The CD mentioned threshold.
We don't have that anymore.
it got taken from us or not the CD maybe in the mirror oh
the CD ah oh my gosh thank you I forgot about you say you
don't endorse threshold testing that's the phrase isn't it
yes except you do Paul because you told me that the students
use that CD in the mirror room I've listened to that CD and
it very clearly mentions threshold testing you keep batting
this away Paul we don't really use hypnosis the students
aren't really tested but I am this close to launching a
full-scale investigation look we get a kickback from these
students and they have to be exceptional of course we have
to test them that doesn't mean we do anything illegal what
do you think we do bump off the ones we don't like well that
depends on how far you push them doesn't Well, we certainly
don't kill them.
Nobody here wanted Kate dead.
I'm sure they didn't.
But what do you expect, Paul, when you put students under
that much pressure?
She was a very, very valuable student.
She was worth a lot to the business.
Really?
And how much would that be?
Well, if you really want to know, 50 grand.
What?
She was worth 50 grand.
Yes.
Why did she have a price?
What, you were selling her?
Of course we were selling her.
You don't get this, do you?
We make perfect employees.
after months that's all we do what do you mean perfect
employees big business needs inspector more than anything
else is none of this altruistic goody-goody crap what we
look for is people with ambition no ethics push greed is
good all right we don't deal with all this comfort stuff the
survival of the fittest that's all there is oh my god no big
plan.
There's nothing at the end of the rainbow.
Except what you have and you can enjoy in the here and now.
And what do you enjoy now, Paul?
Money, money, money!
You're gonna have to excuse me, Inspector, I'm a very...
Yeah, a hobby.
Nurses, yeah.
She enjoys the women.
I'll see myself out.
Oh my god.
Oh!
Hi!
How do you learn your father?
Shut the gate on your way out.
Yeah, it's 11 p.m.
It's midnight.
I gotta go to sleep.
We're gonna eat- oh my god.
He's doing his level best to shut this place down.
Get rid of him.
He's a policeman.
We can't just- You sort this, Ryan.
You man up and you sort it.
tonight oh are we in trouble don't hit R1 and see me outside
the window Kyle this is all Kyle's fault wait is he gonna so
I sit here on my break at work it makes me think blue
raspberry really is the superior fruit flavor candy flavor
that doesn't sound good two totally morally bankrupt men are
plotting to get rid of me.
It's midnight.
I don't have any backup and I don't even have a mobile
phone.
This is potentially quite bad.
And what's Kyle got to do with it?
I think I might make my way over to Atlas while Ryan isn't
there.
Maybe lock myself in.
But what if Kyle's in there?
Oh, so that means the chief is probably like not going to
answer anymore because it's midnight.
We're all on our own now.
Chief, wait!
This is an emergency!
Please!
1-1-9!
9-1-1!
What do they use in the UK?
Oh, no!
Chief!
Chief, you gotta wake up!
Oh, calling the chief after midnight!
Thanks for the double birthday stream!
These past two months have been great, helpful.
I've been recovering from knee fracture!
And your streams have been helping me.
Death to Quarity!
Happy birthday!
Thank you so much for the...
For the Akasuba!
Thank you!
999.
Oh, that's what they use.
Okay.
Happy birthday!
All right, let's go to Atlas then.
Because we're in trouble.
Is it gonna tell us to go... It's time for a final trip to
the woods.
You also have things you're having to ask Simon and Emma
about.
Okay, let's go ask Simon and Emma real quick.
I thought we were going to Atlas.
Not the woods.
Final trip.
Okay, Emma, I'm going into your room.
A few more questions, please.
Thank you.
Do you know whether Kate was in the running to be prime
candidate or not?
I don't, but I do think she would have been chosen just
because she was, you know, Kate.
You didn't discuss it with Kate.
Yeah, we won't fast travel to Atlas.
we'll we'll go through the woods all right let's ask thank
you i wonder if simon's gonna get a little heated about
hearing that kate's a prime status how do you think you'd
have reacted if you'd found out that kate had been chosen to
be prime candidate is that was she i'm just asking how you
think you'd react i don't know i wouldn't react in any way
really i'm not bothered i don't think she was though oh what
makes you think that well it's just an impression i got you
know she's a bit flaky to be honest it's just not really
prime candidate material uh-huh i think he's bothered i
think he's bothered that's it for the time being thank you
all right
she's just not okay goodbye bike well i might never see you
again i might get shot in the woods Okay, I won't get shot.
I might get knifed in the woods.
Oh, geez.
Oh, God.
They're going to get me on the jetty where we found her
body.
Those guys are still fishing.
It's midnight.
Go home.
There's a serial killer.
Kyle's on the loobus.
In the clearing.
Oh!
Oh, shh.
Okay.
What's happening?
Oh!
What is this?
What the hell?
Scotland Yard.
Not hell.
Hello, Inspector.
What are you doing here?
Um, you might want to like let her go with the knife.
Oh my god, he does have a knife!
Come on.
let's have it i don't think you'd understand inspector the
best thing that you can do is turn around go away and leave
us to it knife knife what that knife gives me a perfect
right to stick my nose in investigate and interfere this is
all part of the atlas course it's a physical endurance
exercise drop the knife kyle kyle drop it Oh my god!
Drop it.
Not looking 100% brilliant for you, Ryan.
Well, please, Inspector, you've poked your nose into Atlas's
affairs enough times to know that Imaginative Flair is part
of the course of success.
Our lessons are reinforced by a unique emotional experience.
I almost feel like they should have let her die so that they
could have it.
Extremely evocative, too.
Well, it's a good job you're not in charge of the national
curriculum.
Now look, Inspector, I know what you're trying to do.
I know what you're thinking.
But believe me, Atlas had nothing to do with the deaths of
those people.
Oh, you had a guy who was literally...
...sacrifice in the woods.
That's not what we call circumstantial evidence, Ryan.
Simon.
Now, I saw Simon walking home with Kate last Friday after
the meeting.
Now, Simon had some strange idea that he was in the running
to become prime candidate.
Well, a knob of butter has more chance of becoming prime
minister.
Oh, wait.
so are you telling oh wait what does that mean killed her
well it seems reasonable it's likely isn't it i don't
believe you any more likely than you ryan let's get you home
mysterious girl we don't know who you are big punch him oh
yeah i know police brutality
it's all right are you okay
now in my cape in my mask
you save someone from being sacrificed and that's the thanks
you get if that wasn't an occult ceremony i don't know what
is yeah the rams have been lying all along but what's simon
going to say about ryan's accusation crazy work um so we are
going to atlas oh what does simon oh we have to go I thought
we were going to Atlas when he wasn't there.
I thought we were gonna lock ourselves in.
I thought we were, I thought that was the plan.
Oh.
Damn.
I suppose it was too much to hope that Ryan had left the
place open.
Oh, okay.
Now, now I'm understanding.
All right, let's go talk to Simon.
Simon, was it you?
Was it you?
Ask you a couple more things, please.
Is it you?
What would you say if I said it's been suggested that you
were seen walking home with Kate after Atlas last Friday?
What?
By who?
The same person who suggested that you wanted Kate out of
the picture because you found out she was in the running to
be prime candidate.
Who said that?
Just a question.
I didn't think I was in the running.
It was Ryan, wasn't it?
I am in no position to say.
there's five people in this village i can prove it kate's
driving license give it to me why kate's driving license
please what about see that pattern on the tape there yeah
let me show you something washi tape
see this pattern it literally is washi tape it's the same
pattern this has come from the same roll of tape as this.
Wait, why is that sicker then?
So there's only one person that's taped like that.
He gave me this piece of tape when I was in his office once.
Why, as Kate's driving license, got a piece of Ryan's tape
on it.
I have no idea, son.
Oh, did the subtitle say roll, like, R-O-L-E?
That's funny.
Well, that's obvious, isn't it?
Ryan was testing her.
He was doing a boundary test to see how much she would do,
you would go to be a prime candidate but it all went wrong
okay it's one of the things we do at the course right you
give something that's important to you to someone else such
a weak argument they go and hide it somewhere it's to teach
you to not be bothered when you lose something that's
important that's the wrong lose that's loose gives her
driving license to Ryan Ryan goes where did the She goes
down looking for it.
Probably drunk.
Only he has the tape.
She falls in.
I'm afraid I find that a bit far-fetched, Simon.
It makes perfect sense if you know anything at all about how
Atlas works.
But Simon, if you got the tape from Ryan, Kate could have
got it from him.
He told me he doesn't lend it out.
He lent it to you.
Oh.
But I didn't kill her.
Do a lab test on the card.
will be all over it and what if yours is all over it it
won't be I didn't kill Emma in the other room hearing all of
this screaming just just give me a minute I need I need some
painkillers oh he's taking the opium wait a second we're
just gonna let him do this wait a second what
is happening wait did he just leave did he oh oh oh sorry my
game he go in such a hurry he trying to act as suspiciously
as possible wait I'm so confused her driving oh I guess it
did have this tape but like why like why is the bike gone
into the woods To the jetty.
No.
Uh...
Into the wit.
Into the clearing.
I'm back.
He went to Atlas.
Where the hell did he go?
The bike is still here.
Emma?
Just a few more questions if you don't mind.
Have you seen this anywhere before?
I've seen it somewhere, but can't remember.
Sorry, no.
Only Ryan uses washi tape in this entire village.
Did Simon mention walking home with anyone after the meeting
last Friday?
No, he just came home.
Why?
He didn't mention walking home with Kate.
No, definitely not.
Your boyfriend might be an OPM at the attic.
Who murdered Kate out of jealousy for her prime status?
Oh my gosh, Amazon Prime.
Ryan knit the tape together himself.
Um, wait, let's go.
We don't go like to this village hall very often.
Bike is just sitting back watching it all.
I can't believe we came here to this area for literally one
thing it was those keys and we've never been back here since
oh my god I've been thinking like oh surely there's
something ask about a few more things
please have you seen patterned tape like this anywhere
before Ryan's favorite he painted oh Ryan's got some I know
cuz I borrowed it when was that a couple of months ago have
you still got it I don't think so.
I haven't seen it since then.
Okay.
I saw the tape approximately two months ago.
That's all for the moment.
Thank you.
He's a washi tape dealer.
Is he getting a drink?
Simon?
Simon, where did you go?
Oh, you can't go to there.
Hold on.
You should call the chief.
I thought we were...
I thought that guy was asleep.
Wait, I thought the chief was asleep.
What do you mean?
Couple more questions, if that's okay.
If that's okay?
Detective Jenks, it's 1am, please.
Do you know how well Simon knew Kate?
Not really.
Did you ever see them together?
No, why?
Do you think he killed her?
Maybe.
My game is glitching so bad.
Do you think he'd be capable of that?
Stuttering so bad.
Don't you think we're all capable of it?
No, I don't.
Sure.
So you've never been in your police car responding to an
incident driven past a school at high speed.
I don't know.
Maybe.
Well, you've answered your own question then.
When you've got a need and things get in your way, it's
human nature to either...
Monitor issue.
You know I have been having issues at this monitor too.
Any way you can.
I've been having issues with so many things.
All my stuff is...
Maybe you're right.
Not even that old.
I've been kind of frustrated about it.
Ever seen tape like this anywhere before?
No.
No, but I don't know anything.
I'm just James.
It said we had three things we didn't ask James about.
I don't believe you.
I think I've asked him everything.
I'm just James.
I don't know anything.
Now.
Be that later on if that's okay.
I know.
He didn't even look at the tape.
He doesn't believe in washi tape.
All right, let's go call the chief, I guess, because...
Chief?
Oh.
Just as I guessed, the good...
it great go on Jenks so where to start Paul admitted that
they do use threshold testing apparently they get a wedge of
cash from various companies in exchange for each prime
candidate they produce interesting also I met Ryan and some
of you know chief someone did die in the woods in the middle
of some sort of occult two people actually I have no idea
what they were doing and then we saw good but Ryan almost
gets dad Simon walks Kate home after the meeting last Friday
he's claiming Simon killed her and what does Simon say He
doesn't agree.
Not surprisingly.
He says it was Ryan, because there's something to do with a
piece of tape stuck to Kate's driving license, which Simon
claims belonged to Ryan.
Claims it was Ryan who was testing Kate by sticking the
driving license to a tree in the woods in the dark and
telling Kate to get it, knowing she'd fall in.
And no, before you ask, it doesn't make any sense to me
either.
Right, so basically Simon says Ryan was testing her and Ryan
says Simon was testing her.
Simon says, either of them is mine or neither of them are.
And nobody who is testing anybody.
suppose that's always a possibility wouldn't surprise me
jenks well i don't know i care
everyone's statements the answers in there somewhere call me
back when there's some good news hey preferably a confession
i mean if i can get them yeah thanks chief good night the
heck was that screaming did you guys hear that was that too
quiet on the street it was like ah is it gonna say find the
contradiction
We have a million info.
Wait, okay.
But we also can only talk to two people right now.
We can only talk to Rebecca and Emma.
No, sorry, three people.
We can talk to James, Rebecca, and Emma.
I
think...
Oh, my God.
Let's go start with Emma.
didn't rebecca use the tape to tape up the broken window
i mean she did use a she did use a tape we can't say which
tape we could go check the tape and see
i can't see what does it say oh let's go we can we can try
that
i guess it's a matter of who had the tape right is that what
it all comes down to is the tape a few more questions please
yeah i might have to replay the cinematic that's true
taped over last saw the tape two months ago oh my god are
you freaking kidding me you last saw that sticky tape two is
there only one roll of tape in this entire village so how
come you used last week to tape over the broken window
outside.
That's the same tape.
That washing tape is not even that reliable.
You see, the reason I'm asking is that it's exactly the same
tape that was found attached to Kate's driving license found
at the scene.
The tape that only Ryan has.
Ryan and of course... Why washing tape a window?
It won't even hold!
So what are you saying?
Who's got the tape now?
Do you know where it is?
No.
No, I don't.
know where it is why are you asking me about this tape you
seem nervous rebecca is there a problem well you're
practically accusing me of having something to do with that
woman's murder aren't you i wasn't accusing you of anything
rebecca unless there's something you'd like to tell me no i
wouldn't like to tell you anything okay well that's fine
obviously uh we'll be swabbing everyone in the area for dna
so if anything comes up on kate's license dna traces What'll
come up?
Nothing'll come up.
Right, I've had enough.
I've got to get back.
Would you like to explain to me exactly what is going on?
Which bit?
The fact that some leggy bitch was trying to steal my
husband?
Oh!
I think you had better tell me what you know, Rebecca.
Okay, you want to know what I know?
Kate Vine seduced my husband and was going to blackmail him.
Oh, I think you got the wrong girl.
Not only did she sleep with him, that whore did it just for
his money, our money.
How did you work that out?
I heard her.
I knew it was her arguing with Emma Bowman.
Emma was trying to talk her out of it.
And how did she come to be at the lake?
She dropped that driving license thing when she came in.
Driving license thing.
She dropped a bag.
I took it out to the woods and stuck it over the lake.
Then I waited for her.
when she came out I I told her where it was said someone had
just run off into the woods with it you led her to the lake
she was reaching out over the lake to get it I didn't do
anything she just fell in couldn't let her drown it was dark
I couldn't see anything I couldn't help her really did you
try Rebecca when it was too late she was just about in the
water it was pathetic she was making these gurgling sounds
that sounds like somebody drowning i just pushed her down
with it until she stopped well she was dead anyway what did
it matter you killed her rebecca she slept with my husband
she didn't rebecca what do you mean you got the wrong girl
oh but who
Emma.
It was Emma.
I have to go kill Emma.
Rebecca Rand, I am arresting you for the murder of Kate
Vine.
Oh my!
You do not have to say anything, but anything you do say may
be taken down and will be used in evidence against you.
Do you understand?
Yes.
Sorry.
No.
that Kate's vine's death was a tragic case of mistaken
identity but there are some loose threads here yes there are
what was Ryan doing with Kyle and that girl in the woods I
hadn't interrupted and what really happened to Liam last
year it seems I've only scratched the surface of Atlas and
the Rand business empire trying to find out about Paul
Rand's past is like peering into dense fog he gives nothing
away and covers his tracks with military efficiency however
What is known is that Paul Rand has a lot of connections in
higher places.
Oh my god.
Perhaps James Wilson's ideas weren't too wide of the mark
after all.
Oh my god.
There's still a lot more to learn about the Rand business
empire.
You don't have to excuse us.
Atlas is closed for the moment.
But we'll be open again very soon.
And thanks for your interest.
That's...
Oh my god!
All of that happened.
The cold.
The devil worship.
The sacrifices.
What about the other guy that died?
All for it to be.
The wife?
I...
You know, I'm totally fine.
with it being someone that is like a, like a twist villain!
But oh my oh my god, oh my god.
What happened to the guy that died before?
Maybe he really did just kill himself.
Is this cinema?
Snape was the good guy in the end.
I wouldn't say that.
I think he's just the innocent guy at the end.
What?
I...
Oh, Kickstarter!
Wow!
Oh my...
Oh...
Where did Simon go?
What is this?
all you need to do to crack the case was a roll of tape i'm
i have no she was a femme fatale all along this was an
experimental independent game made on a tiny budget if you
liked it please leave a review of the game and make yourself
heard oh i'm so
the end is cinema just for this reaction
but did kate try simon's whole brew he was a leader of a
cult with connections at high places who might have
disappeared a guy but he isn't part of this case also it
says my progress is 96 percent maybe i missed a
contradiction i think the most baffling thing about this no
everything is baffling i'm sorry a part that really baffles
me is she's just like yeah she slipped into the lake and
then she was making gurgling sounds and splashing everywhere
so i took the stick and just poked her in a little bit like
she was making a stew like she was just like i don't that
was a ride can you unlock this mirror room now it feels
really interesting but not at all built on the wait built
Wait.
Oh, can you unlock this mirror room?
It feels really interesting, but not at all built on, and
the door still stuck.
I'm so...
It wasn't even a murder until the stick.
I'm stuck.
I thought she was gonna say I took the stick and held it out
for her to grab.
No, no.
You just...
It's like she was a...
like she was a carrot floating in your stew and you needed
her to just poked her down a little to cook some more the
folks that made this are working on a new game that's
supposed to come out this year i don't think they've
announced a name yet ah we need contradiction too because
what the hell
is there a what are there achievements for this game is
there a different ending we can get oh oh uh no cheats used
game completed with no cheats are those
are the two locked achievements there's a one no cheats used
you didn't use any cheats during 9 p.m.
and then game completed with no cheats so much build up for
the ending to just move on from it it's just so confused the
tape thing reminds me of heavy rain where the FBI guy uses
the gold watch to prove that the origami killer was a former
cop because no one else yeah the watch is only for cops that
retire literally no one else has that watch no one else uses
this tape i'm i'm also just using washi tape to tape up the
window
you look at it it unpeels itself like it's so i am in such
what what what the
hell was this game
oh oh hi raiders i didn't realize it got raided i just
finished the game thank you so much whoever raided me thank
you thank you sgf2 thank you so much for the gifted i
I don't know what to say.
Oh, Nyaru, thank you!
I'm so...
My goodness.
Wow.
Thank you so much for that.
I feel like the entire game was a red herring.
For example, thank you so much for that.
Thank you!
Oh.
This concludes the washi tape murder and nothing else.
Are we I'm not even going to get Kyle for the attempted
murder.
He was holding a lady up at knife point.
And she just, everybody just walks into the woods and
leaves.
That's it.
T-cup, thank you.
Thanks for the gifted.
No, well, thank you so much for the 20-cup, thank you.
Yeah, he also mugged me.
It was just...
Oh...
Wow.
Thank you so much for the fight.
Get there.
This was so funny.
This game was so funny.
I'm glad I played it.
And also, I'm very confused.
Is that 4% important?
I have no idea.
I wonder if it's because I use the cheat.
Or maybe there was like one contradiction that I didn't
catch.
Wait, there's a final credit scene?
Wait, what do you mean?
Oh.
Oh
yeah, I didn't talk to James, I guess, either.
Maybe the sequel will be out.
been 11 years I'm just it was so like oh yeah they she was
they killed her because she was blackmailing them oh she
died because Simon wanted the position you know I I'm
totally fine with red herrings but now I'm just like it was
because you got the wrong girl because you that she was
cheating that you're that she was cheating with your husband
oh 96% is just a bug apparently oh okay cool Simon's laptop
who stole that the the storage room why were why were why
were OP opioids in the mirror room why did anything happen
Why?
Wow.
That was just crazy.
Well, um...
You had the insurance payout that allowed him to buy a car?
He abandoned his bike.
Wow.
If you missed Jenks' face, check out the shape-shifting
detective.
Oh, thank you.
It's so funny.
To be, if I remember correctly, the creator admitted he had
no idea how he could finish the story.
First time in a Minto thumbnail.
Thanks, boss.
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
I was so funny.
Love seeing you play wacky stuff like this in Mystery of the
Druids.
I love wacky stuff like this.
Truly.
But now, I'm going to bed.
And I'm going to just think about this.
I'm going to mull it over and just be like.
We are not getting this back this time.
This time that we spent on this.
Toriko, thank you so much for the pic.
Have you seen this before?
My bed.
I miss my bed.
Thank you.
This was so funny.
Thank you, everybody.
Have a good day.
Have a good night.
Have a good time zone.
I'll see you when I see you next.
Otsumito.
Props to all the actors because they did really well.
I think so too, yeah.
Actors did amazing.
It's just, yeah.
Otsumito, everybody.
Eat it a-sumito.
Bye-bye.
Good night, good night.
Bye-bye, bye-bye.
See you.
Bye-bye.
It's pitch blue out there.
I'll be safe, yeah.